Das fängt ja schon gut an, geht schon gut los hier, Monarch S.
Was geht so und geht es geht es so euch ja immer immer geht es so mir
ja wir machen heute weiter wo wir gestern aufgehört haben nur mit dem unterschied dass ich schon was
gefixt habe guckt mal her geht mal auf tut euch da kann es euch auch lokal sein geht mal hier
guckt mal da es speichert sich jetzt die änderung es speichert sich jetzt die änderung nach dem
seiten reload und guckt mal hier ich habe eine neue search field gebaut eben gerade noch nicht
mehr mit diesem hässlichen button da unten da kann man jetzt reinklicken und dann irgendwie
nach was suchen zum beispiel guckt ist deutlich besser als dieses hässliche ding was ich gestern
noch hatte wieso nicht über der progress bar weiß ich finde das so viel viel nicer wir können
es auch über die progress bar machen ja und ich habe gesehen guck mal wir hatten den ersten pull
request gestern what the fuck buttons kleiner machen nach breakpoint habe ich habe ich gemercht
und danach habe ich es mit einem force pull über mit einem force push überschrieben weil ich zu
faul war das anzupassen lokal das ist jetzt nicht mehr in der history drin und ich bin ja der der
immer sagt man macht keine force pushs in public repos oder in public branches public repos nicht
das problem er macht keine force pushes in public branches aber da habe ich mir gedacht
aber einfach trotzdem und ihr glaubt gar nicht das hätte ich echt nicht gedacht mir macht
dieser frontend kram wirklich spaß gerade auch wenn es extremer pains champ ist teilweise vor
allem das css geproot force so tests und kommentarier beides absolut overrated
overrated gbated outdated keine ahnung übrigens ich habe letztens muss ich euch jetzt mal hier im
stream zeigen wir gucken uns das nicht an also die ganzen weeps unter uns hier gendet mal
euer hope nicht so high ja aber ich muss euch das einfach mal zeigen wisst ihr was ich letztens
gefunden habe das wurde mir vorgeschlagen von youtube internet explorer chan season 1
es gibt allen ernstes irgendein das ist ja im prinzip animierte comic strips mit
dem internet explorer was auch immer
edge kommt auch drin vor internet explorer evolve dann in einem fight mit chrome zu edge
das ist so richtig over the top shit totaler blödsinn ich frag mich einfach ob es das gibt
gut warum soll es das nicht geben ist ja eigentlich keine schlechte idee es war aber übrigens die
tage die tage des preis champs sind gezählt leute übermorgen hat sich ausgechampft das werde ich
am ersten abschalten rib preis champ vorbei kommt weg übrigens java script ist logisch
oder type of not a number is number zu lull oh nee verbotene emotes hier wieder
ich habe hier ich habe hier auch noch bless rng als emotes drinne das ist auch nicht mehr erlaubt
bless rng ist auch weg
sehr gut wir machen mal weiter da aber nicht so viel wie gestern
habe das ich habe ich merke das immer noch im haus
ihr könnt euch doch dran erinnern ich hatte nicht bis vor ein paar tagen eigentlich noch
als wehe vielleicht keine so clevere idee kurz hier ein bisschen hohli zu machen nicht dass
ich hier nackig sitzen würde oder so aber bis zum haus mal zu machen ich muss jetzt nicht wieder
übertreiben also das habe ich jetzt noch gefixt wir hatten ja gestern das problem dass der ich
und ich glaube wirklich ich habe einen back gefunden wir hatten auch das problem dass der
den status nicht gespeichert hat so und ich zeige euch mal was wir geben wir geben uns jetzt mal
hier den status von diesem globalen to dus objekt aus so und ihr werdet sehen ach nee
jason stringify wer ist denn dieser jason eigentlich so und wenn man jetzt hier was
aktualisiert werdet ihr sehen guckt der setzt hier dann immer auf true und falls so aber was
der nicht gemacht hat ist also er bekommt offensichtlich die updates mit was der aber
nicht gemacht hat ist die custom hooks im store laufen lassen was die sachen in local storage
speicher das ging nicht und ich bin mir relativ sicher dass das ein back ist weil das to dus
objekt wird hier aktualisiert aber die custom hooks laufen nicht so und warum bin ich mir
relativ sicher dass das ein back ist naja ich zeige euch mal wie ich das ganze gefixt habe
dass es jetzt doch funktioniert ich habe einfach gesagt wenn sich to dus ändert dann setze
to dus neu was absolut keinen sinn ergibt aber funktioniert also wenn sich to dus aktualisiert
hat dann aktualisiere to dus mit sich selbst das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn dass es
notwendig ist aber dann funktioniert so die custom hooks laufen und ich glaube deswegen
dass das ein wirklich ein richtig echter back ist den wir gefunden haben im wie heißt
das so reactive tracking binding was auch immer guckt ich kann es euch zeigen wenn ich
das hier aus kommentiere so ich kommentiere das aus es funktioniert alles aber wenn ich
reloade ist der zustand nicht gespeichert weil diese save hooks hier nicht laufen so
und aktualisiere ich nach dem aktualisieren mit mir selbst was allein schon von der aussage
absolut bescheuert ist dann funktioniert es guckt und deswegen denke ich das muss ein
back sein weil wo ist denn der sinn dass ich die aktualisierung ja offensichtlich mit bekomme
sie aber zurückschreiben muss in den store weil er ja sich aktualisieren muss das ergibt
überhaupt keinen sinn so und ich glaube das ist echt ein back und guckt mal wie ordentlich
ich jetzt hier dieses sorting machen konnte hier guckt mal so wir haben jetzt unsere to
dus die to dus sind aber nicht sortiert aber wir wollen die to dus ja sortieren nach dann
alle die abgehakt sind soll nach unten und nach erstelldatum das neueste soll nach oben
ne das älteste soll nach oben und das neueste soll nach oben ich weiß nicht warum wir das
sortiert haben und da habe ich eine massive big brain seite gefunden das habe ich mir
einfach copy paste copy pasted kann man sich die geschweiften klammern sparen guck mal
da ist es noch kürzer so und da habe ich was gefunden im internet ich habe keine ahnung
was es macht aber man kann sort by property sortieren also ich kann jetzt also meine to
dus haben ja pelder id created mit einem datum drin den text ob es gelöscht ist und ob es
abgeschlossen ist und das kann man wohl hiermit irgendwie filtern lassen exzellent keine ahnung
aber das ist jetzt richtig richtig gut zu lesen also wenn presa rief da ist das ist ja jeder
selbst ernannte spell master hacker man erklär mir mal please warum man das hier braucht
dass es funktioniert mach jetzt mal klammern drum warum braucht man das damit meine custom
hooks auf den store laufen obwohl er ansonsten ja mitbekommt dass er updated wird keine ahnung
ich glaube wirklich dass es ein bug ist ich glaube wirklich dass es ein bug ist weil
weil wie gesagt der bekommt es ja mit wie gesagt er bekommt es ja mit man sieht
er jetzt aktualisiert sich aber der lässt die hooks im store nicht laufen der store
selber bekommt es mit ja guck sonst würde das hier nicht funktionieren der store selber
bekommt es mit du siehst ja dass ich das aktualisiert das ist ja quasi direkt der
store selber der store selber bekommt es mit aber wenn ich moment ich mache das mal raus
ich habe es ja noch drin aber du siehst also guck der store bekommt es mit der store bekommt
nene die methoden werden das normalerweise geht aus normalerweise geht das gwent wenn
ich anstatt sortata schuld zahldig direkt tutti verwendet dann geht's dann geht's so
fort?티this tracking dieses tracking war dass ich was ändert geht irgendwie unterwegs
Dadurch, dass das über so eine durch so eine reactive variabel durchgeht und
Was muss ich aber nie sehen und nachdem es aber im store obwohl ich gesortet to do's verwende nachdem es sich ja im store
aktualisiert aber die store hooks nicht laufen
Gehe ich davon aus dass es ein bug ist deswegen brauche ich so merkwürdige dinge wie wenn sich to do's
Aktualisiert hat dann überschreibe noch mal es mit sich selbst dass die hooks laufen also ich gehe davon aus dass es sind bug
alles andere wäre irgendwie nicht nach vollziehbare magic
Ich habe auch versucht mal auf github danach zu suchen aber ich weiß nicht so genau was ich suchen soll zumindest habe ich nichts gefunden
So
Da sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben
Ich glaube nicht dass das layer 8 problem ist und wenn ja vielleicht ist es ein layer 8 problem
Aber dann hat ein pallet ja unten drunter irgendwie einer was nicht so ganz logisch gemacht
So also wo machen wir denn heute weiter ich würde sagen ich mache mal kurz hier meinen ganzen krempel zu
Sonst wird es ein bisschen unübersichtlich
So read me wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Also suche suche haben wir guck suche funktioniert
Was nicht funktioniert irgendwie spezial so was der fack ich werde spezial suchen so eins oder zwei oder so das machen wir auch nicht wir machen
Einfach eins zu eins case insensitiv volltext suche
guckt hier das ist unsere suche die wir machen
text zu
lauer case lokel wen interessiert lokel keck weh
zu lauer case
includes to lauer case also im prinzip wir ignorieren einfach ob es groß und klein geschrieben ist also wenn ich zum beispiel
ein to do habe
Wo keine ahnung anstatt titel keck weh drinne steht und ich suche jetzt hier nach keck in klein
Finde das auch oder wenn ich nach keck in groß suche oder wie auch immer geartet finde das
Löschen geht auch noch
Vielleicht musst du ja auch so ein store update machen das problem ist ich habe keine möglichkeit an irgendeiner stelle ein store update zu machen
Weil das hier direkt auf das to do gebeindet ist ich kann ja kein custom custom zeug ausführen
Wieso er die zweier findet wo findet er die zweier
Was
Ach so ja warum findet er die zweier chat dreimal dürft ihr raten
Ihr könnt es nicht wissen aber da steht keck weh drin
In dem
Bade
Aber war kein absichtlicher tschübett als als als hätte ich das jetzt vorbereitet oder so
aber das steht da mit drin so ja gut wo machen wir jetzt weiter wie gesagt es funktioniert alles
also was haben wir als nächstes hübsch gemacht haben wir wir haben das tatsächlich das muss man
echt mal sagen ich glaube das ist meine man muss mal abhaken moment wie ging moment der kunde mark
down icsen ging das so weiß ich guck mal mal brief mark down preview ne gab es nicht möglich konnte
man nicht in mark doch irgendwie schön schön schön icsis icsis machen irgendwie mark down sein check
der gov floor das mache ich doch ist das vielleicht github genau das ist irgendwie
special github markdown das hier ist normales magda wobei das auch nicht normales magdaun ist
weil normales magdaun braucht lehrzeichen am ende für neue zeile ok ich sag nix das ist das ist
normales magdaun also dass das hier und zwei unterschiedliche zeilen sind es auch github
magdaun normalerweise müsste man zwei lehrzeichen dran machen für neue zeile wäre auch immer auf
so eine bescheuerte idee gekommen ist man kann aber das preview man kann das preview doch bestimmt
umstellen settings wir gucken jetzt mal magdaun preview breaks
kann man das nicht auf auf gfm umstellen
kann man nicht wie es kaut magdaun preview gfm github flavoret das schmeckt nach github pepo fett
oder muss man jegliche sache irgendwie
magdaun preview render github flavoret
das support github no wie es kauta es kommen magdaun using na geil da
brauchst wahrscheinlich echt ein plugin für was sollen das scheiß alle das gehört jetzt
mittlerweile sogar dem gleichen laden wollen die mich rollen oder was was ist hier los
microsoft denkt sich einfach nur egal wir machen jetzt einfach so häkchen hin so das
haben wir gemacht hübsch gemacht den komponenten ausgelagert haben wir bei dir geht's
jetzt nicht was ich da anders machen sollte
das ist exakt so wie die das hier ein beispiel haben magdaun preview github flavoret visual
studio code plugin github styling jawoll es hat nur 523.000 installationen
du hast welche extension magdaun all in one peers code visual studio code hat so krass
viele extensions mittlerweile mach ach nur drei millionen dreieinhalb millionen installationen
das ist ja ist ja nix und das ist next level magdaun shit wofür ist das da all you need
for magdaun keyboard shortcuts preview na gut hauen wir einfach mal rein china chinesen
plugins installiere ich immer am liebsten
magdaun view auf der shell ja das könnte man auch verwenden somit autoreload oder so
aber ich hab das hier lieber im editor drin ok install oh nu magdaun preview all magdaun
oder einfach nur das preview öffnen und es passiert nix ne das reicht nicht was muss
ich jetzt machen magdaun all in all all preview ne wie macht man da jetzt das preview von
auf scheint big brain time zu sein geht nicht so einfach print current document to html
ne hab ich jetzt n html angelegt hier drin oder was zack ja ja wie wie wie macht man
das sein preview kann er zu kompliziert sein review overview overwrite open review toggle
preview ok open preview ne alter wir halten uns hier schon wieder mit zeug auf extensions
wo ist es warum steht das nicht unter extensions drunter
control kv kontrol shift v kontrol shift v
um die
haben wir gemacht. Auslagerung in Komponenten, Slots und Events haben wir gemacht. Wohlgemerkt,
man muss sagen, das ist doch mittlerweile echt ordentlich im Vergleich zu dem anderen Zeug,
was wir sonst so fabrizieren. Guck mal, das kann man richtig gut lesen. Unser Main hat
jetzt gerade mal 80 Zeilen, ungefähr 80 Zeilen und es ist alles gut lesbar. Man kann jetzt
nicht sagen, das wäre irgendwie großartig kompliziert. Ja. Und die Suche, die Suche
ist richtig pork, guck mal hier. Heck weh. Seht ihr, seht ihr mal auch, guckt mal, wenn
ich hier reinklicke in die Suche, es ist nicht nur, dass die Suche sich ausbreitet, ja, dass
sie sich erweitert, sondern der, das Icon mit der Lupe, guck mal, das wird auch blau,
wenn man reinklickt. Wie die Umrandung. Seht ihr mal, wie pock das ist? Das ist Tailwind,
das ist Tailwind Magic und zwar macht der Fokus hier, Fokus within, also sprich, wenn es fokussiert
ist, dann setzt der Text auf, also nein, wenn der Fokus irgendwo in diesem Diff drinne ist,
dann setzt das Text auf blue und ansonsten ist halt Text grey und hier unten ist halt
kein Text gesetzt. Richtig, Magic. Alter, komplett ohne Javascript hier. Wir können
auch noch mal kurz die Huge Animation bewundern, guck mal hier. Hier, die ist slided. Wo kommen
eigentlich diese komischen, dieser komische Rahmen, das ist noch irgendein Hover-Effekt
oder so. Egal, machen wir jetzt weg. Duration 75, perfekt. Gut, dann würde ich sagen, können
wir weitermachen. Was machen wir als nächstes? Dark Light Theme, das würde ich wahrscheinlich
noch mal ein bisschen aufschieben, das ist eher sowas für Brain AFK. Wir haben jetzt
aktuell Dark Theme und eigentlich ganz gut. Das ist eindeutig Advanced-Thema. To Do's
Liste Sharing als Link. Ein Delete All-Button. Also ich glaube ein Delete All-Button dürfte
relativ easy sein. Musik nennt ein bisschen laut. Geht eigentlich ganz gut. Also ein
Delete All-Button ist easy, das können wir jetzt gleich machen. Da haben wir unten einfach
einen zweiten Knopf. Wobei, ich glaube ein Delete All-Button neben dem Add-Button ist
vielleicht ein bisschen... Chain-Lo ist wieder da, guck mal da. Ich glaube so ein Delete
All-Button neben dem Add-Button ist vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht positioniert. Shortcuts
könnten wir uns überlegen. Nur bin ich nicht ganz sicher, wie man Shortcuts im Browser
fängt. Das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Wie fängt man Shortcuts im Browser ab? Wie bekomme ich
Shortcuts? Das müsste doch, also nix sagen Chat, nix sagen. Das müsste doch eigentlich
relativ easy sein. Ich bräuchte so ein On-Click-Event für die gesamte Seite. Wie auch immer ich
ein On-Click-Event für die gesamte Seite bekomme. Gibt es sowas wie Window-On-Click? Also sowas
wie Window-Click? Nee. Ah, Key-Down, nee. Svelte-Window, ah yes, excellent, guck ich wusste
doch die Leute sind schlau. Svelte-Window, Special-Elements, Svelte-Window-On-Key-Down,
Alter ist das wieder 5Head was da eingebaut ist. Guckt euch das doch mal an. Massive 5Head
Poggers, Big Brain Time. Das war jetzt glaube ich so der Twitch Chat. Leute, ich muss euch
was erzählen. Ich spiele ja gerade nebenbei wieder 20 Jahre altes MMO auf einem Test-Server
so nebenbei und ich hab nen Char der heißt Pepega. Weiß nicht wie er bis danach war.
Zumindest ich hab gestern mit ein paar anderen Leuten zusammen PvP gespielt und wir haben
uns ernsthaft mit einem anderen aus der Gruppe hab ich mich in Twitch Emotes unterhalten.
Und was sieht man daran? Wenn sich Leute in-Game in einem 20 Jahre altem MMO mit Twitch Emotes
unterhalten dann weiß man das ist Mainstream und ist angekommen. Welches MMO Dark Age
of Camelot auf einem Test-Server hier? Bin es interessiert. Atlas, FreeShot, da. Ist
aber komplett Test und wird gevibe am Ende der Testphase. Also das ist nur was für Leute
die früher auch da auch gespielt haben denke ich. Zumindest fand ich das äußerst erfrischend.
Ich hab geschrieben für alle im Chat so nach dem Motto hier I'm tired AF was weiß ich ich
geh ins Bett und dann hab ich reingeschrieben Bettge und dann hat der andere Typ darauf
geantwortet Zetge. In einem 20 Jahre altem MMO da wird man denken die Leute sind noch
mehr Boomer als ich. Da wird man davon ausgehen die Leute sind noch mehr Boomer als ich aber
nein Twitch ist mittlerweile so Mainstream das funktioniert. Aber die Musik ist mir grade
zu belastend. Mumu jawoll. Ja Twitch ist auch bei Mainstream Boomer angekommen das heißt
schon was. Ok Handle Keydown. Function. Function. Handle wir wollen nicht Keydown gibt es nicht
einfach. On Key oder sowas. On Key Press ist mir lieber. So. Hand. Nein. Handle. Easy.
Quatsch was mach ich denn da Handle Key Event so rum muss das sein. Lock Event. Was jetzt?
Warum Error? Nö kein Error. Keyboard Event. Porkas Hagger Man. Ok Maus Event gibt es wahrscheinlich
nochmal extra. So also wo ist der Unterschied zwischen Svelte Kit und Svelte. Svelte ist
das eigentliche Framework und Svelte Kit ist was was die Arbeit ein bisschen einfacher
macht. Zum Beispiel hast du in Svelte Kit deine Routendefinition pro Feil also legst
ein Feil an der macht automatisch eine Route draus. So und Svelte Kit unterstützt dann
beispielsweise auch dass du die Seiten schon mal prerendern kannst auf dem Server bevor
du sie rüber schickst. Also du brauchst Svelte Kit nicht. Svelte Kit macht manche Sachen
ein bisschen einfacher oder naheliegender. Aber ansonsten ist das alles Svelte. Was cool
ist ist Server Side Rendering also dieses Prerendern von den Seiten weil du bekommst
die Seite quasi schon vorgerendert geschickt und der Browser muss sich dann bloß noch
übernehmen und nicht erstmal quasi 10 MB JavaScript drunterladen dass er anfangen kann
die Seite zu rendern. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau. Das ist so das beste aus
beiden Welten. Früher hattest du quasi nur Server Seiten die Seiten gerendert. Zwischenzeitlich
waren Single Page Applications übelst angesagt dass du alles kleinseitig gemacht hast und
jetzt so eine Mischung
das ist nicht Friday oder heißt die Musik so. So also Handle Key jetzt kriegen wir die
Key Events auf der Seite und jetzt muss ich gucken also wir machen jetzt zum Beispiel
sowas wie Alt Enter würde ich sagen Alt Enter legt ein neues Emote an oder nicht ein neues
Emote was erzähl ich dir? Neues To Do. Alt Enter neues Neues To Do. Alt plus Enter neues
To Do und oder Control Enter und Alt plus D gleich dann. Probieren wir das mal aus
ist ja nur zum testen. Also das war doch irgendwie Modifier oder sowas. Wie man das raus bekommen
konnte ob einer. Achso. Ah ne Alt plus D geht nicht Alt plus D ist. Wäre Tab nicht
besser als neues To Do ich verwende Tab meistens. Weiß ja. Alt Key genau. Ich brauche jetzt
irgendwas was nicht schon belegt ist. Moment ich brauche Keys die nicht schon belegt sind
vom Browser. Was ist denn zum Beispiel frei? Das ist ja alle schon belegt und der erkennt
auch nicht das. Guck mal der erkennt auch nicht wenn ich was mit Modifier drücke. Kann
es sein dass das On Key Press nicht funktioniert? Sondern dass ich Key Down wirklich brauche
dafür. Ja Key Down ja. Das sollte jetzt Alt Key True sein ja. Okay Key Down muss es
sein. Oder Key Up. Verstehe. Aber lieber Key Up dann passiert das. Wobei ne wir machen
es bei Key Down dann passiert es gleich. So wir machen jetzt was passiert wenn ich Enter
drücke. Keyboard Event. Key Enter. Wir testen es jetzt einfach mal damit. Also Alt Enter
bedeutet also If Event Key gleich Enter und E Punkt was war das? Alt Key dann Add To
Do. Gucken wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert. So ich bin irgendwo auf der Seite und jetzt
Alt Enter. Bäm. Leute neues To Do am Start. Massive. Deshalb 50 Milliarden To Do's. Okay
jetzt muss ich ganz schön lang klicken bis da wieder. Excellent. Vielleicht hätte ich
auch gleich lieber All Clear All Button machen sollen. Ähm Moment Chat was? Mein
Luzent lässt nach dem Kommentarding immer ein Leerzeichen. Ich mach das auch so. Ich
mach auch gerne Leerzeichen. Es ist aber würde ich sagen ziemlich Geschmackssache. Genau
und das Schließen. Du hast recht. Sackfalte. Bester Name. Hier können wir einfach gucken
ob wir in dem Feld drin sind und dann schließen wir es. Wieso benutzt du eigentlich Wishl
Studio Code anstatt Wishl Studio? Weil für so Frontend JavaScript Sachen Wishl Studio
Code deutlich besser ist. Der JavaScript Support in Wishl Studio ist PaintsChamp und du hast
gerade in Wishl Studio Code schon out of the box ziemlich guten JavaScript Support. Dazu
kommt dass du Milliarden an Extensions hast für alles was du brauchst. Guck mal zum Beispiel
mal ein gutes Beispiel für wenn man zum Beispiel Icons einbinden will. So. Icon. Icon. Was
mal als Beispiel. So und jetzt ich benutze hier Iconify für und jetzt gibt es ein Plugin
für das Autocomplete der Icons inklusive. Inklusive Vorschau wie die Icons aussehen.
Das ist halt das geile an Plugins. So. Fügen wir das ein. Bam. Das habe ich irgendwie kaputt
gemacht weil ich das Code vergessen habe. Und schon haben wir das Icon drin. Kannst
dann auch sagen wir wollen Tweemoji haben. Tweemoji. Tweemoji wollen wir den Döner.
Oder das Taco. Taco. Bam. Hat Tweemoji Taco drinne. Wir können dann jetzt sowas sagen
wir hier Class Text 8XL. Jetzt haben wir ein großes Taco. Bumba Dings Bums Bada Bums Dings
alles klar. Poggers. 18 Monate am Start. Wir können auch Cookie. Cookie. Das ist aber
ein XL Cookie drinne. Oder Kappa. Ah nee Kappa heißt das nicht. Das ist ja Moon offiziell.
Das ist ja Hull Moon. Hull Moon Face. Thanks to JetBrains Fleet wird Visual Studio Code
übertreffen. Ich denke die werden denen ganz schön Konkurrenz machen aber ich glaube in
dem Fall nicht dass es das übertreffen wird weil es einfach Java versus Javascript ist.
Du wirst tausendmal mehr Leute finden gerade für Frontend Sachen die die Sachen in Javascript
programmieren wollen als in Java. Solange Plugins in Fleet in Java programmiert werden
wird für Frontends Geschichten denke ich zumindest Visual Studio Code weiter das Ding schlechthin
bleiben. Bin mal gespannt. Ich stelle mir Fleet eher in Richtung so Sachen wo es keine
offiziellen Ideen von JetBrains gibt. Aktuell ist es so man will Rust programmieren. Es
gibt ja ein ganz gutes Rust Plugin für diese ganzen JetBrains Dinger. Dann verwendest du
standardmäßig IntelliJ und machst dann irgendein Plugin für rein. Obwohl du eigentlich gar
nicht IntelliJ haben willst. Für sowas ist Fleet gut. Dann stelle ich mir zum Beispiel
vor du nimmst Fleet dann machst du das Rust Plugin rein hast eine ganz gute Rust IDE.
Du nimmst Fleet und machst das BrainFuck Plugin rein hast einen ganz guten BrainFuck Editor.
Haben die Ruby? Die haben RubyMine die haben auch für Ruby was. Für welche halbwegs verbreitete
Programmiersprache hat JetBrains eigentlich nichts? Flutter zum Beispiel. Flutter könnte
es ein gutes Fleet Plugin geben und gut ist. Oder für das meiste haben die ja schon. Für
das meiste haben die ja mittlerweile irgendwas. Aber da hälst du schon zwei Sachen. Du machst
ein Rust Plugin rein, ein Flutter Plugin und hälst eine ganz gute IDE dafür. Ohne dass
du den ganzen IntelliJ Kram drumherum brauchst. Rubey haben sie. Die haben RubyMine. Habe
ich früher auch mal verwendet als ich noch viel Ruby gemacht habe aber jetzt gar nicht
mehr. Also wir drücken Alt-Enter und es gibt ein neues To-Do. Das ist doch schon mal Pog.
So und dann wollen wir. So und dann wollen wir wenn wir klicken. Wie machen wir das jetzt
dass es Closed wird? Also es gibt zwei Sachen. Zum To-Do Closen. Wir könnten entweder das
global machen und dann schauen welches To-Do gerade aktiv ist. Oder wir machen das in der
To-Do Component. Oder wir werfen ein Event in der To-Do Component. JetBrains hat nichts
für Haskell. Ja dann auf gehts. Fleet Plugin. So wie machen wir das jetzt mit dem schließen?
Also wir wollen auf jeden Fall schon mal. Brauchen wir kein else. If. If Key ist was
was? Was hatten wir gesagt? Ach so hier Alt. Wenn es D ist. Alt und D okay. 0W. Alt und
D ist dann zum schließen. Und jetzt müssten wir an der Stelle noch wissen was das aktive
To-Do ist zum schließen. So und da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher wie wir das machen.
Entweder track ich das hier drinnen was aktiv ist. Oder ich werfe oder ich machs im To-Do
selbst. Wahrscheinlich ist es im To-Do Handeln sinniger. Dann ist das auch gekapselt und
dann muss ich da keine Gedanken drüber machen. Also Text Area. Key Down. Machen wir das jetzt
inline? Machen wir das jetzt inline? Dann muss das aber Quoten. Nee Klammern machen
sonst funktioniert der Kram nicht. If. Ich hab keine Ahnung ob das so funktioniert.
Schauen wir mal. Mal gucken. Wenn Key D und Alt Key dann. Dann To-Do dann gleich True.
Kann man das so schreiben? Nee natürlich nicht. Muss man bestimmt nochmal klammern.
Excellent. Okay Alt D. Bäm. Funst. Easy. So und jetzt müssen wir das. Wir brauchen aber
zwei Sachen. Wenn man nochmal Ctrl D drückt dann wird das wieder Entdant. Wieder geöffnet
quasi. Entdant wird das dann. So also das wollen wir auf jeden Fall schon mal hier nicht
als Inline Funktion haben. Das ist ein bisschen hässlich. Handle. Handle. Close. Oder so.
Handle. Key. Hardle. Hardle. Key. Stimmt! Der Byte Strikes ist schlau. Natürlich. Das
ist viel einfacher. Byte Strikes ist richtig big brain heute am Start. Guck mal.
Ja. Vorgass. Nice. Ja das ist das. Ich mein. Chat was sagt ihr? Inline oder extra extra
Funktion hier oben. Ich glaub wir können schon eine extra Funktion machen oder? Das checkt
doch sonst niemand der das durchguckt. Handle. Key. Um. If. Äh Moment. If. Ey das ist Mario
Galaxy oder? Das ist Mario Kart irgendwie Mario Galaxy. Ja. Das ist die Regenbogen Strecke
oder? Aus Mario Kart 8. Oder? Nee hatte die Mario Galaxy. Ach keine Ahnung. So. Kunst.
Chat. Ich versteh das Ende nicht ganz. Du prüfst auf all die und prüfst das mit dem
mit einem und und. Ach du meinst das hier. Du meinst. Als ich das so geschrieben hatte.
Das ist das das das funktioniert wahrscheinlich in den meisten Programmiersprachen aber das
in JavaScript funktioniert. Wundert mich. Wundert mich nicht. Und dann war das hier
noch eine extra extra Funktion. Also das da ist eine anonyme Funktion. Weil. On click
oder on Keydown halt eine Funktion haben will. Und und sonst nichts. Das hier ist quasi
ein Ausdruck den man auswerten kann in JavaScript. Kann ich dir auch zeigen. Das ist quasi was
weiß ich. Das gleiche wie so. Ach so ups. Niede. Das ist halt ein Ausdruck da kommt
True oder False bei raus logischerweise. So. Und das verknüpft du einfach zu einem quasi
weiteren logischen Ausdruck. Oder am Ende auch True oder False rauskommt. Aber dadurch
wird es quasi ein Ausdruck den JavaScript auswertet. Deswegen musst du es nicht klammern.
Du hättest es auch klammern können und extra. Also. Du könntest auch hier drin jetzt ein
ganz normales If machen. Dann musst du es aber klammern. Wenn du das in einer Zeile
schreiben willst dann muss das ein Ausdruck sein. So. Und was hier rauskommt ist das kann
man im Prinzip ausprobieren. Keine Ahnung das da. Und dadurch dass es ein und und ist
wird das zweite nur ausgeführt wenn das erste True ist. Weil es ist ja logisch wenn man
sowas hier hat. Oder keine Ahnung. Dann muss der das zweite also machen wir es umgedreht.
So. Der muss also das ist jetzt stellvertretend für ein Ausdruck der True oder False ergibt.
Wenn das erste False ist dann muss er das zweite nach dem und und ja gar nicht mehr
auswerten um das Ergebnis zu wissen. Also. Stell euch mal vor das hier ist ein Ausdruck.
Da sag ich zum Beispiel 1 gleich gleich 1 und 2 gleich gleich 2. Oder 2 gleich gleich
1. Hier kommt False raus. Hier kommt True raus. Das heißt um zu wissen was B ist muss
der das hier auswerten. Weil es ist True. Und er weiß er muss das zweite auswerten
um zu wissen was da was bei B rauskommt. Hätte man jetzt sowas hier stehen. Dann wertet
er den ersten Ausdruck aus und erkennt aha. Der erste Ausdruck ist schon False. Das heißt
ich muss die zweite Hälfte gar nicht ausführen um zu wissen dass B False ist. Ist ja auch
irgendwie eine Optimierungsgeschichte. So. Und das hier ist im Prinzip nichts anderes
wie das. Nur dass man nur das in JavaScript aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Was das funktioniert
übrigens nicht. Das funktioniert übrigens nicht in jeder in jeder Sprache. Du kannst
zum Beispiel. Also ja für JavaScript ist hat das hier einen Return Wert. Ehrlich gesagt
kein Plan warum. Also was weiß ich. Let B gleich 0. So und jetzt wenn ich sage B gleich
1. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das in Ordnung. Dass das keinen eigentlichen Bool Return Wert
hat. Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer warum das in JavaScript erlaubt ist. Da gibt eigentlich
keinen Sinn. Aber das funktioniert. Es Lind. So was benutzen wir hier nicht. Wir haben immer
gut selbst dokumentierten fehlerfreien Code. Da braucht man sowas nicht. In anderen Programmiersprachen
mit sinnvollem Typing. Geht das nicht. Also wenn du sowas in C sharp ausprobieren willst.
C sharp Lab ist das glaube ich. Also wenn du sowas in C sharp machen willst klappt das
nicht. Und KS wo sind wir hier. Also wenn du in C sharp beispielsweise sowas machen willst
hier was ich in B gleich 0 und dann willst du und dann willst du überprüfen sowas wie. Ich meine
der erste Teil funktioniert noch. Aber da kannst du nicht einfach sagen. Ja. Irgendwie if. Und
und wobei mit if geht es ja auch so nicht. Das ist schon so so so so pains. Das ist mir da gar
nicht so. Und und B gleich 1. Das lässt er dich hier an der Stelle schon gar nicht machen.
Er sagt was. Was zum Teufel. Wie willst du. Bitteschön. Bull Operator und Int miteinander
unter einen Hut bringen. Also das ist. Ich würde fast behaupten. In den meisten Programmiersprachen
die irgendein Default Return Type haben für alle Statements klappt das. Aber in normal geteilten
Sprachen klappt das nicht. Was man in C sharp machen kann ist zum Beispiel wenn man was
abbrechen will. Man darf. Man kann glaube ich sowas hier machen. Das oder oder throw.
Oder nicht. Ich bilde mir ein sowas ist jetzt eigentlich erlaubt gewesen. Das könnte aber
auch in einem anderen Kontext sein. Wir haben nämlich was geändert in einem letzten Version
das sowas in der Richtung jetzt geht aber anscheinend an der Stelle nicht. Egal das
ist nicht unser Problem heute. Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben. Wir können unser To
do Closen. Und öffnen wieder. Ist eigentlich alles was wir machen müssen. Mehr müssen
wir nicht machen. Wir können unser To do öffnen und schließen. Und wir können mit alt enter
beliebig viele To do anlegen. Wenn wir wieder reinklicken macht das wieder auf. Eigentlich
genau das was man haben will. Man könnte jetzt. Man könnte vielleicht noch sagen.
Wenn man entfernen drückt. Was haltet ihr von der Idee wenn man entfernen drückt auf
einem geclosen To do. Dass man es löscht. Hast du schon mal ein Fim fürs Programmieren
ausprobiert. Ja ich hab früher. War ich richtiger Hardcore Wim. Und ich verwende Wim eigentlich
auch immer noch täglich aber halt nur für irgendwelche. Dinger wo ich in der Kommando
Zeile bleiben will. Also nur wenn ich in der Kommando Zeile bleiben will. Ansonsten
mache ich da relativ wenig mit. Zumal. Ich hatte früher den Tick. Ich habe versucht
mein Wim übelst aufzubohren. Mit Fuzzy Search Geschichten mit irgendwelchen Python Plugins
mit JavaScript Gedöns und sonst was. Und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht Alter. Du bastelst ja
mehr an deiner Editor Konfig und an deinem. Dass dein Editor halbwegs bedienbar ist rum
anstatt irgendwas sinnvolles zu machen. Ach Papierkorb. Nee in Papierkorb gibt es noch
nicht. Das machen wir als nächstes. Wir machen als nächstes den Papierkorb. Also wir machen
jetzt genau. So. Wir machen jetzt die Shortcuts. Genau die drei Sachen machen wir jetzt. Shortcuts.
Ach ja genau du hast recht. Ja genau das meine ich. Richtig. Richtig. Der Chat hat
recht. Ich meine das hier. Eins. Gleich. Gleich. Zwei. Und dann. New Exception. Kekwe. Oder
auch nicht. Aber ja ich meine ich meinte ich meinte meinte das. Ich bin mir gerade nicht
mal sicher wie man es benutzt. Das haben die in einem der letzten C-Sharp Versionen eingeführt
dass du quasi jetzt Exceptions werfen kannst an Stellen wo du eigentlich irgendein Statement
schreiben müsstest. Aber zur Abkürzung. Dass du quasi wenn du eh einen Error werfen willst
das an der Stelle machen kannst. Nee nee nee das meinte ich nicht. Ein wie heißt das Ternary
Operator. Ach. Keine Ahnung das sind so Nischendinger die braucht man so selten. So. Also entfernen
können wir machen. Was für einen Knopf kommt denn wenn man entfernen drückt. Log. E. Was
für einen Knopf kommt wenn man entfernen drückt. Delete. Aha. If. E. Delete. Sagt mal. Ist
das hier. Hat das jemand schon mal mit TypeScript gemacht. Ist das hier eine getypte. Irgendwie
Enamoration oder was auch immer in TypeScript. Also hat TypeScript autocomplete für die
Keys dann die es gibt. Das wäre ja schon cool. Oder vielleicht dies. So if key delete. Dann
remove to do. To do Punkt ID. Oh. Ja nice. Oh Moment das funktioniert. Ich muss checken
ob es. Ich muss checken ob es. To do und dann und und. So das kann ich nämlich sonst alle
löschen. Guck jetzt passiert nichts und wenn es jetzt dann ist dann kann ich es löschen.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. So. Faut nicht so auf. Stell dir vor jemand will den
Text eines fertigen to do's ändern und löscht plötzlich sein to do. Kann er Feature Request
aufbauen auf GitHub. Nee aber du hast schon recht das ist vielleicht keine all zu clevere
Idee wenn man einfach entfernen drückt. Du willst dir was reinschreiben und dann. Dann
funst das nicht. Aber zu Testzwecken finde ich das gar nicht mal so verkehrt. Sonst
jetzt muss ich mir jetzt eine ordentliche Tastenkombination ausdrücken. Was ist denn
eine gute Alt. Alt. Alt entfernen. Bäm Alt entfernen. Und und. Alt key kommt noch dabei.
Alt entfernen. Das drückt keiner einfach mal so. Alt entfernen. Also wir haben jetzt
Alt Enter anlegen. Alt D zumachen und Alt entfernen löschen. Das finde ich ok. Das
können wir so lassen. So next. Papierkorb. Ja Papierkorb wird etwas komplizierter. Aber
ich glaube die grundsätzliche Sachen. Ein Andubutton ist eine gute Idee. Das ist aber
auf jeden Fall. Ein advanced Thema. Papierkorb haben wir die grundlegenden Sachen schon da.
Weil. Wir haben schon ein Feld. Deleted für die To do's. Aktuell löschen wir die ja
wirklich. Ja kein que. Also aktuell ist ja wenn ich hier drauf klicke. Dann löscht er
das ja wirklich komplett. Was wir jetzt machen müssten ist nicht. Richtig die To do's löschen
sondern. Eigentlich nur noch sagen. To do. Deleted. Gleich true. Aber da wird jetzt erstmal
nichts mehr passieren. Wenn er mal drauf klickt. Aber ich muss jetzt hier. Filter. Ich muss
die deleted die deleted rausfiltern. Also filtern. To do. Bringst hier mal mal die Klammer
weg. To do wo es not. To do. Deleted ist. So. Ok. Oh ich muss mein local storage löschen
da sind noch To do's drinne. Da sind noch To do's drinne wo diese neuen die dieses neue
property gar nicht haben. Oder wir löschen sie. Ja Funst. So. So jetzt zeigt er nur noch
jetzt zeigt er nur noch die To do's an. Die. Nicht deleted sind. Ok. Lull. Gut. So und
gucken wir mal in local storage rein. Das sollten jetzt. To do's drinne sein. Die deleted sind.
Hier zum Beispiel. So und jetzt müssen wir eine Möglichkeit einbauen um das anzuzeigen.
Wie was für To do's deleted sind. Da habe ich aber ehrlich gesagt keine gute Idee zu.
Was war da ein erster Gameboy in grau. Ich glaube ich hatte den klassischen den ganz
klassischen alten Gameboy der da 19 was weiß ich in 89 oder so raus kam. Und den gab es
gab es den nicht nur in grau und später gab es den dann glaube ich auch in rot und so
aber ich glaube am Anfang gab es den nur in grau. Hat den in grau. So jetzt haben wir
die Möglichkeit unsere To do's zu markieren. Als. Oh. Das ist schlecht. Wobei ne das ist
ok passt. Ja jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir die Möglichkeit unsere To do's zu markieren
als deleted. Die Sache ist bloß die wie hat jemand eine eine clevere Idee für den Papierkorb.
Und wie stellen wir das dann wieder her. Braucht es einen neuen storage für die deleted.
Ich meine wir könnten einfach ein Filter einbauen. Show deleted. Wir machen genau wir machen
einfach den Toggle hier oben hin. Show deleted oder sowas in der Richtung. Und dann zeigt
da alles an. Also nur mal so mal so als Beispiel wir machen jetzt einfach mal einen sehr hässlichen
Button. Button. Ja und dann genau da könnten wir die komplett durch gestrichen unten drunter
und unten drunter. Ja. Show deleted gleich Pauls. Und klick. So langsam lärm ich. Und
klick. Show deleted. Ne das müssen wir jetzt so machen. Gleich not. Show deleted. Wo ist
der Button hin. Der Button hat kein Text. Klick. Ja massive Button. Gut jetzt jetzt
toggle das deleted auf true oder false. Show deleted. Genau. So und jetzt können wir anhand
dessen das filtern. So nämlich hier hier filtern wir deleted raus. Und dann sagen wir einfach.
Wenn. Show deleted. Und und. Oh. Warte mal. Nee. Moment. Das ist die Logik. Die Logik
ergibt keinen Sinn die ich hier gebaut habe. Also Filter. Show. Moment ich will jetzt nur
wenn es nicht. Nee warte mal oder oder will ich. Show deleted. Ja. Im Prinzip ist. Eigentlich
das die Logik oder. Ja. Kunst. Jetzt jetzt jetzt zeigt er einfach alle an. Guckt. Wubbel
Wubbel Wub. Reload. Ja. So ist sie open und dann bräuchte man oder. Wieso habe ich doch.
Ich habe dann als Date. Und deleted als Date. Aber sagt der Chat dazu. Genau und jetzt den
Restore Knopf anstatt dem. Massive. Der Chat ist wieder hier. Expanded. Mega Gehirn. Definiere
verschiedene Filter für alles deleted search. Du nimmst eine Variable in der steht immer
welche Filter Funktion gerade stehen. Könnte man auch machen. Ja aber das passt doch wenn
das deleted ist dann ist das icon ein Restore Knopf. Das ist richtig schlau der Chat wieder
hier exquisite high IQ. Way to smart Hacker Mans. Ja. Also. Gehen wir mal in to do rein.
Wir lassen das jetzt übrigens standardmäßig zum testen mal auf show deleted auf auf true
stehen. Man könnte sich noch überlegen wenn man das umschaltet auf show deleted dass
er nur die gelöschten anzeigt. Und die normalen gar nicht. Egal. Egal. So. Und jetzt tauschen
wir das einfach aus. Hier ist das icon für remove. So und das icon für remove jetzt
müssen wir den if machen ins Welt da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher wie das funktioniert
irgendwie so wahrscheinlich. Aha. Wobei das if muss ja da außen drum herum. Was ganz
was anderes. Warum habe ich hier überhaupt noch ein extra diff drumherum warum mache
ich das click nicht auf das icon. Gebt dem Kram hier unten die classes und macht es weg.
Warum mache ich das nicht. Weil. Weil on click bei icon nicht funktioniert. Ja das ist ja
ziemlicher pains. Genau. Und click ging ja nicht auf icon. Jetzt weiß ich wieder warum
ich den Mist habe. Also brauchen wir if. So if. Das to do deleted. Dann das und ansonsten
else das. Else war glaube so. Ich finde also ich weiß nicht was das für eine für eine
big brain Syntax ist. Die finde ich nicht schön wenn ich ehrlich bin. Was hat er jetzt
für was was will er hier von mir jetzt. Ach so weil das empty ist. Also da muss ich sagen
da finde ich die Vue.js Syntax viel schöner. In Vue würdest du sowas machen. Vue if und
dann würdest du sagen. Else. Das wäre das Gegenstück dazu. Ich weiß nicht was jeder
schöner findet aber. Ich. Bin da jetzt auch kein all zu großer Fan von dieser Syntax
ehrlich gesagt. Man erkennt schon was deleted ist. So und alles die deleted sind die kriegen
ein extra Button. Die Vue Syntax findest du ganz schlimm. Ich finde die eigentlich nice.
Wir brauchen ein gutes Icon für Restore. Hero Icons. Gibt es dann Restore. Sowas. Ok wir
machen jetzt mal Iconify. Wir suchen jetzt mal ein gutes Icon für Restore. Bros Icons.
Restore. Ja sowas wäre richtig gut. Such mal nach Return. Ne gibt es nicht. Sowas wäre
halt richtig cool ne. Aber das passt halt vom vom Design her überhaupt nicht zu den
anderen Icons. Da muss man ja schon genau sein. Re. Sowas. Ich meine. Ich finde das
ist gar nicht so schlecht dafür. So. Also ich fand das fand das hier mit. Fand das
eigentlich besser. Was war schöner. Der Kasten ja. So. Machen wir es mal so. So jetzt wollen
wir allerdings nicht remove machen sondern. Restore to do. Übrigens allein schon dass
ich hier I.D.s übergebe ist ziemlich beknackt. Weil. Ich brauche überhaupt keine I.D.s mehr.
Can't wait. Restore to do. Ist auch sehr einfach. Wir setzen einfach die I.D.s wieder auf. Ich
glaube viel simpler kann es nicht sein. So. Oh. Ich habe es geprägt. Oh. Oh je. Äh.
Was habe ich gemacht. Was habe ich falsch gemacht. Das mit den I.D.s. Das mit den I.D.s
ist eigentlich nichts Schlimmes. OK. I.D.s. Ich übergebe jetzt einfach eine I.D. um der
I.D.s übergeben Willen. Nicht dass man das brauchen würde. Jetzt geht. Hä. K. Häh.
Ist das wieder die Geschichte wo ich das da eigentlich machen müsste.
Das ist ja hängen geblieben. Warum geht das denn mit Parametern und ohne Parameter geht
das nicht. Ist ja dumm. Zack. Komm mal hier. Und sonst sind sie wieder restored. Sind
sie gelöscht. Alle löschen. Bäm. Restore. Zack. Hawkchamp. Übergibt doch direkt to
do. Nee ich muss da gar nichts übergeben. Es gibt nur einen to do. Deswegen die I.D.s
sind eigentlich komplett unsinnig. Ja aber. Aber guck mal. Hier habe ich doch auch Klammern.
Da müsste er sich da nicht stören. Da kann ich nicht ausführen. So. Jetzt machen wir
das hier mal wieder weg. Wo ist mein hässlicher Button. Da brauchen wir jetzt einen Switch
oder so. Ach nee. Erst mal gucken was das mit den Funktionen jetzt hier auf sich hat.
Ich meine ganz im Ernst. Scheiß drauf. Wir machen das jetzt einfach so. To do. Delete
equals false und unten drunter deleted true. Fertig. Kunst. Ich glaube das ist die deutlich
einfache Variante. Oder. Oder wir würden das machen. Was der. Ich glaube ich gesagt hat.
Wir würden sowas machen wie Funktion toggle deleted oder sowas. Wisst ihr was. Was für
extra Funktion oder in line. Also extra Funktion würde dann so aussehen. To do gleich deleted.
Not deleted. Aber was ich nicht was ich jetzt nicht verstehe ist. Aber wenn ich das dann
einfach so reinschreiben würde ohne Klammern das würde dann gehen oder wie. Würde das
jetzt funktionieren. Ach das geht jetzt oder was. Das ist quasi Pointer Pointer auf die
Klammern. Und wenn ich so sage fühle das direkt aus. Aber was ist der Unterschied zwischen
so mit einem Parameter oder Parameterless. Weil da müsste man auch meckern. Cannot cannot
execute. Wie dem auch sei wir hinterfragen wir hinterfragen da die JavaScript Geschichte
nicht weiter. Das ist jetzt einfach so. Swell Magic. Ok. Verstehe. Was denn. Macht das if
über die Icons und der Button um die Icons. Ah ja ja das ist eine gute Idee. Wir machen
das. Wir machen das wirklich so. Wir machen das if so. Innen drinnen. Weil das hier oben
ist ja immer gleich. Wir machen das if quasi. Hier rein. Und das if hier rein. Das schmeißen
wir weg. Da machen wir das. Und das. Schon wieder schon ein bisschen übersichtlicher.
Übrigens wir machen so das nicht alle angezeigt werden. Ich habe es mir anders überlegt.
Das ist zu das ist zu verwirrend. Wir sagen Show deleted. Und wenn die to do's deleted
Ups. Ich will die eigentlich filtern. Ich will inzwischen umschalten können. Das ist
richtig. Du machst trash icon by deleted. Warte mal. Habe ich jetzt falsch rum? Ach
so. Ich habe es falsch rum ne. Das hier marscht gerade nochmal weg. Das war Blödsinn. Title.
Und jetzt. Das können wir so lassen. Das müssen wir nicht inline machen. Das können
wir ruhig so lassen. Was jetzt halt cool wäre irgendwie wenn wir da nicht so unterschiedliche.
Warum braucht man das? Warum braucht man das doppelt? Könnte ich nicht. Moment. Wir checken
jetzt. Moment. Wir machen jetzt big brain play. Kann man nicht einfach anstatt das hier das
icon dynamisch beinden. Dass ich quasi sag icon. Moment. Ich muss mal ausprobieren.
Und dann. Wenn to do deleted ist. Dann machen wir hero icons das da. Und wenn das nicht
deleted ist. Dann machen wir hero icons trash. Oh. Was jetzt? Ach so ich habe es nicht gequotet
ich noob. Ja das funktioniert nämlich auch. Das ist dann nämlich viel kürzer und knackiger.
Sagen wir das noch so. Ich mein warum kann er. Ach so weil der ist eigentlich viel längerer
Text ist. Ja die Sackfalte wusste es wieder. So und jetzt machen wir noch den Filter.
Also da muss ich jetzt binary logic. Also wenn show. Ups. Wenn show deleted ist. Dann will
ich. Dann will ich checken ob das to do auch wirklich deleted ist. Nicht to do's alter.
So. Jetzt heißt jetzt so zeigt er nur die to do's an. Kann man umschalten die. Das ist
quasi Papierkorb Ansicht jetzt. Das ist quasi Papierkorb Ansicht. Nur die die. So. Und
dann machen wir die Papierkorb Ansicht wieder aus. Und dann müssen wir jetzt noch filtern.
Also quasi show deleted. So und jetzt können wir sagen. Oder. Oder. Ne Moment. Und. Ne.
Jetzt. Jetzt. Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Dieses Reactive Label ist richtig big brain. Ich
mein. Das kann es jetzt ja nicht sein. Das muss doch einfacher gehen oder. Und das funktioniert
immer noch nicht. Moment meine binary logic Dinger sind gerade nicht. Hier ab vor den
task. Ich will einfach switchen. Also wenn es. Nicht show deleted ist und. Das müsste
doch eigentlich so funktionieren oder. Low IQ. Chat ihr müsst mir helfen. Hä? Hä?
Hä? Hä? Also ich habe keine. Ich habe keine mehr die nicht gelöscht sind. Es funktioniert
oder. Ich muss nur welche löschen. Ah ok. Alles klar. Hat alles funktioniert. Ok. Hier
lege ich. Aber das muss doch trotzdem einfacher gehen. Ich meine was ist denn das hier. Und.
Und. Das. Irgendwie wieder strebt mir das. Das muss man doch einfacher schreiben können.
Wer ist gut in binary magic. Das ist jetzt einfach so. Könnt ihr pullrequest machen.
Wem es sich gefällt. So. Ja wunderbar. Das hier ist jetzt quasi die Papierkorb ansicht.
Das ist die Papierkorb ansicht. Guckt hier. So. Das müssen wir jetzt nur noch. Das sind
jetzt alle. Das sind jetzt alle gelöscht. Die können wir jetzt einfach alle restoren.
Jetzt der Papierkorb leer. Ja. Ey wir müssen übrigens hier oben bei der progress Anzeige
alle gelöschten rausfiltern. Guck mal sonst kann das nicht funktionieren. Das show. Not
show deleted ist da unnötig. Nee wenn ich das weg mache dann würde der immer. Egal
was ich was ich also wenn wenn show deleted. Quasi. Also. Auch wenn show deleted an ist
würde er dann alle die nicht deleted sind anzeigen. Ohne diesen filter davor. Ich habe
heute morgen gepusht. Was passiert wenn man in der Papierkorb ansicht ein neues Element
hinzufügt. Dann wird ein neues Element hinzugefügt aber man sieht es nicht. Sondern man sieht
es erst wenn man switcht. Ja das sind so die details. Wir brauchen noch ein Papierkorb
leeren icon. Ein so richtig so richtig Papierkorb Papierkorb leeren icon. Wir machen es zum
testen hier oben wieder eins. Clear. So. Und da was weiß ich. Empty Trash oder so. Show
deleted gleich gleich. Ja. Du hast recht das müsste eigentlich funktionieren ja. Klingt
logisch. Der Chat wieder. Hier guck mal da. Big brain time. Massives Gehirn wieder. Das
liegt einfach daran dass die ganzen Prime Sub schon einfach so den Wahnsinns IQ Boost
ausgelöst haben. Dass der Chat mittlerweile so viele high IQ Leute hat. Das ist einfach
schon quasi von Twitch nicht mehr gehandelt werden kann. So nice. So jetzt brauchen wir
noch ein True. Und jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Clear Button. Empty Empty Trash machen
wir jetzt. Empty Trash. So Empty Trash heißt wir filtern alle To Do's die also To Do's
Ne. To Do's gleich. To Do's. Filter. Alles was nicht. Alles was nicht deleted ist wird
gelöscht. Ok. Clear. Bam. Dann können wir den Papierkorb wieder schließen. In der Papierkorb
an sich könnte man das Add Icon durch ein Empty Trash. Alter. Der Chat ist ja richtig
Expanded. Expanded hier heute. Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf mit Massive Ideen hier.
Das ist eine super Idee. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee. Manchmal hat es echt seinen Vorteil
wenn man nicht einfach alleine da ist und daran rumfrickelt. Warum muss Empty Trash Reactive
sein mit den. Muss es nicht. Das hier ist die Zuordnung weil das weil To Do's ein Store
ist. Und ein Store kannst du nur accessen mit dem Dollar davor oder alternativ so. Das
ist die Store. Store Assign. Operator oder wie immer das heißt. Keine Ahnung. Das hat
in dem Fall nichts mit Reactive zu tun. Ja das machen wir jetzt. Wenn man in Papierkorb
an sich sind dann. Moment mal machen wir das mit dem Clear. Add Button. Wo ist der Add
Button. Da. Wenn wir im. Gibt es denn ein schönes Papierkorb so Trash Empty. Nee gibt
es nicht. Ok wir ersetzen das mal nur durch Trash. Empty. Gibt es so etwas wie Empty.
Recycle. Vielleicht sollten wir einfach einen anderen Icon Font nehmen der mehr Zeugs drin
hat. Weil der ist schon sehr limitiert. So aber dann machen wir das doch an der Stelle
mal. Das Icon ändert sich einfach entsprechend dem Status. Also wenn wir in Active. Nee Moment
wie hab ich den Kram genannt. Nee nicht Search Active. Show Deleted. Also wenn wir in der
Papierkorb ansicht sind. Dann machen wir ein Papierkorb Icon hin und wenn wir in der
normalen ansicht sind machen wir das normale Icon hin. Probieren wir das schon mal aus
ob das funktioniert. Trash. Ja. Wir sind in Papierkorb. Ich lösche mal kurz was. Wir
sind in der Papierkorb ansicht. Dann ist das unten ein Clear All. Und wir sind in der normalen
ansicht. Dann ist das unten ein Add. Das finde ich eigentlich relativ clever. Byte Strike
alles klar. Ist das die Assembler Variante vom Papierkorb oder wie? Nee das ist irgendwas
was du von Stack Overflow kopiert hast wahrscheinlich. Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus. So und
jetzt müssen wir noch gucken, dass je nachdem in welchem Modus wir sind, was unterschiedliches
passiert. Also on click kann man. Ok das ist jetzt die Frage. Kann man hier drinnen checken?
Kann man hier drinnen checken? Geht sowas? Nee wie habe ich es gerade? Empty Trash. Meint
ihr das? Funzt es? Ok jetzt wenn tu du es. Nee es funktioniert nicht. Das funktioniert
nicht. Ach Moment. Das ist auch falsch rum. Falsch rum. Ah. Oh das ist ja nice. Das ist
ja richtig nice. Lul. Zum Programmieren bin ich quasi gezwungen Englisch zu können.
Nee aber es ist von Vorteil, wenn du die Sachen in deinem Source Code in Englisch schreibst.
Weil ansonsten hast du das Problem, wie wenn Franzosen irgendwas programmieren, dass die
Variablen dann auch Französisch sind und das checkt dann keiner mehr. Ja genau. Das
kommt auch noch dabei. Tutorials und Webcasts und Konferenztalks und sowas sind eigentlich
auf Englisch. Aber man muss dazu sagen, es ist ein Unterschied ob du jetzt irgendwie
Englisch in einem Film verstehst oder gar Englisch reden kannst mit Leuten oder ob du
irgendwie IT Englisch Sachen verstehst. Also das ist nochmal ne Runde weniger anspruchsvoll.
Ich könnte mal wieder pushen wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ich deploy gerade mal ne Runde
wieder. Ansible Playbook. Damn. Ja aber so komplett ohne Englisch sagen kommt es nicht
aus. Das ist übrigens auch der Grund warum ich den Browser und mein Betriebssystem komplett
auf Englisch stehen habe. Ah zwei Gründe. Erstens ist man findet Fehler deutlich einfacher.
Also wenn man in die Windows Settings guckt und danach irgendwas sucht, wenn man das auf
Englisch sucht ist es einfach viel einfacher zu finden. Und weil es doch irgendwie Wörter
gibt wo man sich halt, also auch technisch, zum Beispiel dass das Flight Mode heißt wüsste
ich jetzt nicht so standardmäßig. Das ist halt dieser Wi-Fi und alles an aus Modus oder
was auch immer wie die Sachen so genannt sind. Das finde ich ganz praktisch wenn man
das eigentlich täglich so mitbekommt ja. So. Also jetzt haben wir hier unser Papierkopp
Modus. Das ist eigentlich richtig nice. Das gefällt mir echt. Guck mal hier wir löschen
den Kram jetzt, gehen in den Papierkopp Modus, können es entweder Restore oder wir löschen
alles. Wir könnten vielleicht noch eine Abfrage machen. Englische Tastatur mag ich aus irgendwelchen
Gründen nicht. Das kann ich nicht so genau sagen warum, aber englische Tastatur mag
ich nicht. Übrigens die hier oben machen wir doch irgendwie einen Switch oder sowas
ne für. Ok. F*** was wollte ich jetzt machen? Bumer Gehirn schlägt zu alter. Ne falsch hier
der. Und ein Hover Info wenn man die Maus drüber hält. Ja, könnte man auch machen.
Ich war an den Alert wollte ich noch machen. Weil wir programmieren jetzt keinen eigenen
Dialog oder? Wir können Alert machen oder Dialog auf Popup vom Browser benutzen. Also
empty empty trash, Dialog, ne nicht Alert. Was ist denn das Gegenstück zu Alert mit
ne Abfrage? Alert with yes no Browser. Prompt war es, Prompt, genau Prompt nicht Dialog.
Prompt, Message, delete all Fragezeichen. So if BAM zack. Ok ne das ist Javascript Logik
die funktioniert anders. Options. Alert Prompt wurden deprecated. Tja. Confirm. Ah yes.
Das will ich haben. Delete all ok genau das will ich haben. So hier delete Papierkorb
Ansicht. Delete all ok BAM. Confirm will ich haben. Exquisite. Ja sehr nice. Ich mein
theoretisch müssten wir ja ein eigenes Overlay machen. Aber ihr wisst wie meine Poggers CSS
Skills sind. Eigentlich nachdem ihr habt recht das ist deprecated. Eigentlich müssten wir
ein Overlay mit Z-Index machen. Also wir müssten quasi sowas hier machen. Style Z-Index 9999
oder sowas. Das probieren wir jetzt mal schnell. Komm wir machen den eigenen Dialog. Lull.
Glass. Wir brauchen keine Ahnung Breite Höhe. Pull. Pull. Ah ne brauchen wir nicht. Es muss
absolut sein. Nein es muss fixed sein. Oder Static. Static muss es sein. Wie macht man
am besten so ein Overlay. Static. Background. BG Red einfach so das man das sieht. Ok. Und
jetzt right. Right Null. Top Null. Bottom Null. Left Null. Ne. Ok how to. Ah so. Nicht
Static. Absolut. Oder vielleicht sogar fixed. Fixed. Ok alles klar. So wir haben ein Overlay
am Start. Es war kein schönes Overlay aber wir haben ein Overlay am Start. Opacity 50.
Ja ok ok wir kommen der Sache schon mal näher. Jetzt kann man hier auch nicht mehr durchklicken
das ist schon mal sehr schön. Ja und meine Key Events werden auch nicht mehr gecrapped.
So wir haben ein Overlay. Wir haben ein Overlay. Ich habe das jetzt nur rot das man es erkennt.
So und da drinnen bräuchten wir jetzt noch das eigentliche Dialog Fenster. Also Diff.
Das ist Blurry. Oh ja Blur. Blur SM. Wie macht man das Tailwind. Tailwind Blur Background.
Backdrop Blur. Backdrop Blur MD. Ja wie macht man das Blurry. Ok CSS Blur nicht Background
Blur. Opacity. How can I make it CSS Class Blur Effect von Overlay. Aha aha. Ja genau
sowas hier wollen wir haben. Backdrop Filter Blur. Also das funktioniert schon mal nett.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wie ich das Blurry mache. Das muss der Massive IQ Chat wissen ich weiß
das nicht. Blur Overlay. Genau. Overlay. Einfach nur Blur. Filter. Filter Blur. Und
dann 10px. Hey hey da macht was. Da macht was. Ich erkenne aber nicht was. Ja Moment
der Blur ist nicht unten drunter sondern mein eigentlichen Background. Das ist aber nicht
so Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Ich habe legit keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert. Also mit
Backdrop war schon mal nichts. Backdrop. Tja Leute. Keine Ahnung. Das ist jetzt eure Aufgabe
wir suchen aber CSS Set Index Blur. Ne ne ne mit Class Backdrop. Ok. Zeig her wie hat
das, wie hat das gemacht. Ich erkenne da nix geblurrtes. Ich erkenne auch nix geblurrtes.
Der Blur muss auf das Stift drauf wo deine ganzen Hintergrund Elemente zum Blurren drauf
sind. Ah. Ich müsste quasi sowas setzen wie. Ah verstehe. Ich müsste quasi sowas setzen
wie Overlay aktiv. Overlay aktiv und dann müsste ich quasi sowas wie sagen wir hier
auf der. Auf der Liste müsste ich dann sowas sagen wie Blur. Da muss ich sagen Diff. Diff
rum rum machen. Der Twinko Moin. So und jetzt was? Style? Filter? Jetzt kommen wir jetzt
hier schon. Bei so komischen CSS Dingern. Ne ne ne so funktioniert das nicht. Ne. Ach
so Moment ich hab hier gar nix was angezeigt für den Lul ich kann noob. Natürlich funktioniert
das guck mal. Funktioniert alles. Ich bin nur zu blöd. Funktioniert alles. Oh hier wird
geblurrt. Komm her. Huge Blur. Alles klar verstehe verstehe. Ich hab kapiert wie es
funktioniert. Der Chat hat aber auch immer so super advanced Feature Ideen. Kann ich
Svelte Window Blur machen? Geht das? Geht. Ne. Ne. Wie Blurre ich denn die komplette Seite?
Ich hab sowas wie Svelte Page oder so. Body? So vielleicht. So. Ne. Svelte Blur. Ne. Ne.
Svelte Blur. Body. Was? Head? Ne oder? Den Head? Ne. Svelte Blur. Body. Svelte Blur.
Geht das überhaupt? Lass mal eben kurz in die Sache rein. Body? Hier auf dieses Route
Diff müsste eigentlich jetzt ein Style kommen. War der Blur vielleicht nur nicht sichtbar.
Listeners. Es ist nur Listeners. Es hat nichts zu tun mit. Ah. Oh der Chat ist wieder richtig
big brain. Ok verstehe. Svelte Head. Ok ok. Svelte Head. Kann man das noch schließen
irgendwie? Head. Svelte Head. Style. Body. Aha. Alter Filter. Blur. Nicht Blut. Blut
Blur. 10 Pixels. Ah. Renax macht hier nichts draus ich auch nicht. So und jetzt müssen
wir das ganze nur noch irgendwie dynamisch. Jetzt müssen wir das ganze nur noch dynamisch
hinbekommen. Wie bekommt man das jetzt dynamisch hin? Weil ich will das ja nur anzeigen wenn
der Dialog aktiv ist. Also ja Klasse setzen und löschen. Das könnte man tatsächlich
machen ja. Also dass wir dann sowas machen. Body. Was ist Blur oder so? Aber jetzt wird
doch auch der Dialog Blurred. Das stimmt wohl. Jetzt wird auch der Dialog Blurred. Oder?
Jetzt wird auch der Dialog Blurred. Aha so einfach ist es doch nicht. Ich meine ich
hätte eine richtige Noob Idee. Wir würden einfach das hier oben lassen und das da unten
alles in den Diff schmeißen. Komplette Seite in den Diff. Und das machen wir wieder weg.
Und sagen einfach hier mal zum testen irgendwie Style. Filter Blur. 5 Pixels. So und jetzt
gucken wir mal ob das Overlay ich hab da gar nichts reingeschrieben ob das Overlay überhaupt
davon. Ne das Overlay passt. Nice. Ja weil hätte ich das vorher gemacht mit dem. Das
probieren wir jetzt noch mal kurz aus. Hätte ich das vorher gemacht. Was war das Sveld.
Hätte ich das nämlich vorher gemacht dann würde der wahrscheinlich auch das Body dann
würde er auch das komplette Dialogding Blurren. Der Chat hat wieder hier so anspruchsvolle
Ideen. So ja genau jetzt blurrt er auch den Dialog. Alles klar ok. Ja dann müssen wir
das komplett wrappen. In ein Diff. Find ich so ein bisschen doof aber ok. Gibt es da nicht
einfach ein Model? Ne ich hab nichts drinne an irgendwelchen fertigen CSS Sachen. Müssen
wir alles selbst bauen. Dann wär das ja easy. Dann wär das ja easy. Ah der legt immer noch
Sachen an. Ok widmen wir uns der Sache gleich. So jetzt haben wir ein Overlay. Wie triggern
wir das Overlay überhaupt. Wir wollten. Sekunde ich bin grad viel. Das Overlay soll passieren
wenn man auf den Button zum to do. Also anstatt des confirms das eigene Overlay. Gibt es
nicht Standard HTML Element für Models inzwischen. Keine Ahnung ob sowas gibt. Nö anscheinend
nicht. Die machen Diff und CSS Stellz. Nö. Nö nö nö. Gibt es anscheinend nicht. So
wir wollen das öffnen. An der Stelle wo. Hier. If confirmed. Das ist aber schon ein
bisschen eklig da müssen wir da ne eigene Komponente oder so draus machen. Also empty
trash. Click. Mozilla Element Dialog. Ok wenn Mozilla weiß da Bescheid. Also. Das ist doch
bestimmt einfach nur so Syntaktik Ding was eigentlich gar nichts macht oder. Die haben
doch jede Menge Sachen eingeführt in HTML die einfach nur Syntaktisch sind und eigentlich
gar nichts ändert. So was für navigations bar Artikel und sonst was die eigentlich nur
für die Optik sind und nichts machen. Aber mal gucken vielleicht ist das so. Haben die
was zum ausführen. Aha das einer irgendwelche. Ja genau der hat der hat der hat eine Komponente
dafür. Ja ja auf die auf die Idee wäre ich auch gekommen jetzt schon. Und hier unten
machen sie was. Da gibt es. Da gibt es wirklich irgendwas fertiges dafür schon. Tiger Chat
ja habe ich geändert. Das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren. Das wusste ich gar nicht
dass es so was gibt. Ok das Copy Paste wieder jetzt einfach rein. Allerdings ohne irgendwas
soll einfach nur hier Dialog Kekwe. Guck mal das wird standardmäßig nicht nicht gezeigt.
Document Get Element ich meine das ist sicherlich nicht die Welt Art. Aber wir können schlecht
da jetzt irgendwas komplizierteres drum bauen. So und dann triggern die das so. Das ist bestimmt
nicht bei allen wetten mobile Safari wetten mobile Safari und supporte das nicht. Komm
mal da. Richtig Park. Wenn das geht nicht mobile. Mobile Safari Alter. Mobile Safari
kann nix. Ok Firefox kann es auch nicht. Das ist Internet Explorer nix kann. Ok ok ok das
lasse ich mir gefallen. Ok das ist nix wo man sich darauf verlassen kann dass es da
ist. Ja unter IOS da habe ich ja mal ein Video zugemacht das fand ich lustig. Safari da
haben die Leute gesagt Max das stimmt nicht was du sagst die haben einfach hier ich hatte
dazu ein Video gemacht. Chrome auf IOS existiert nicht. Ja ein bisschen klickt bei den Titel
aber ok. Und da waren wirklich müsst ihr mal durchgucken sind Leute in die Kommentare
die sagen Max das stimmt nicht. Ich meine ich erzähle einfach das komplette Video so
wie es ist ich zeige sogar glaube ich ich habe nicht sogar Links auf die Apple Guidelines
oder. Was ist denn das eigentlich für Anzeige da unten. Was haben wir haben wir irgendwelche
komischen YouTube Plugins oder sowas. Warum sieht die Seite so komisch aus. Warum kann
ich warum kann ich die Videobeschreibung nicht aufmachen. Das neue Design. Also wie gesagt
ich habe da glaube ich sogar Apple Entwickler Richtlinien irgendwie drinne gezeigt wo das
wo das hier. Wo das drin steht Store Guidelines und sowas. Ich habe das sogar gezeigt im Video
und die Leute schreiben trotzdem in den Kommentaren ne ne ne das ist nicht so. Also ich habe
Firefox installiert auf meinem iPhone. Das ganze Video geht darüber dass Firefox nicht
Firefox ist sondern eigentlich Safari. Aber die Leute checken es wieder nicht. Nein nein
ich habe Safari installiert bei mir auf dem iPhone. Die lecken richtig huge critical information.
Aber aber aber extrem critical information lecken sie. Übrigens zum Thema dumme Leute
auf YouTube. Es hat mich ja wieder fertig gemacht. Wenn man sich die Kommentare hier
teilweise durchliest. Egal ich will es nicht davon anfangen. Aber die Leute waren so richtig
abgedreht. Pepega wieder im Kopf. Unglaublich. Also wo sind wir jetzt. Wo sind wir stehen
geblieben. Wir wollten den Dialog ansteigen. Let's show. Das ist rein zu rein zu Übungszwecken
hier jetzt. Ich würde das wahrscheinlich normalerweise nicht so implementieren. So
Show Dialog. Der wird nur angezeigt. Also das ist mit Vue schon. Guck mal in Vue würde
ich jetzt so machen. Vue if Show Dialog fertig. Aber geht nicht. Also müssen wir jetzt nicht
dieses komische if wieder machen. If. If. Show Dialog. So. Und wenn wir jetzt auf
Clear drücken. Empty Trash. Kommt jetzt Show Dialog gleich True. Zack und jetzt geht der
Dialog an. Sehr gut. Das mache als eigene Komponente aber. Hast du Lieblings UI Komponent
Leibniz? Ja. Das womit ich fast alles gemacht habe. Nachdem mir das übrigens auch mal
jemand im Stream vor 2 Jahren oder so oder 3 Jahren empfohlen hat. Ich habe fast alles
was ich danach irgendwie halbwegs ernsthaft gemacht habe damit gemacht. Einfach weil es
easy ist und ich hauptsächlich die Sachen in Vue gemacht habe. Der Preis Champ ist beispielsweise
auch Vutify. Obwohl man das eigentlich, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, eigentlich überhaupt
nicht braucht für so eine Seite. Wozu brauche ich irgendein komisches Komponent Framework
für eine Seite die ein paar Icons hat. Ja. Aber zum Beispiel hier das Overlay. Das Overlay
habe ich mit Vue gemacht. Easy. Ja. So. Programmiere den Scheiß mal selbst. Guck mal das macht
sogar den Hintergrund dunkler. Und auch das hier oben den Filter und sowas.
So. Aber wir sind ja gerade am üben. Deswegen machen wir das jetzt selbst. Also hier wird
der Dialog angezeigt. Okay. Der ist im Hintergrund. So und jetzt müssen wir das noch blurren.
Also Style. Brauchen wir Style. Style. Blur. Filter. Blur. Was haben wir gesagt? 5 Pixel
oder so. So. Und das machen wir nur. Glass. Blur. Wenn. Wenn Dialog. Ach ne wir müssen
das so machen. Wenn Dialog. Show Dialog ist. Also. Zack. Und es ist geblurrt. Massive.
Huge. Blur Logic. Warum ist das Icon auf einmal da oben? Warum ist das Icon jetzt da oben?
Chat. Ich sehe es genau das das Icon da oben ist. Was macht es da oben? Das darf da nicht
oben sein. Warum ist das da oben jetzt? Man erkennt es kaum aber es ist da oben. Ich sehe
es genau. So Dialog. Da brauchen wir jetzt noch ein Button drauf. Button. Close. So und
Close. On. Click. On. Click. Wollen wir jetzt einfach machen irgendwie Show. Vielleicht
Falls. So. Close. Hä? Was ist das? Moment. Was haben wir bei dem Icon irgendwelchen Blödsinn
drin stehen? Fix. Vielleicht ist es das. Vielleicht muss ich es absolut machen. Keine Ahnung.
CSS Kickweight. Kein Schimmer. Keine Ahnung was das für Schmerzen hat. Chain of Plague
nicht so ein Blödsinn. Du kennst die Antwort doch genau. Du schreibst das nur, dass du
Ausrufezeichen Frage machen kannst. Meinst du ich erkenne das nicht oder was? Das ist
der Chebat Versuch wieder. So Show und Dialog. Wir ignorieren jetzt mal, dass dieser Button
dort auf einmal an einer Stelle ist wo er eigentlich gar nicht hin sollte. Was macht
dieser hässliche Button da? Gut. Und jetzt brauchen wir da drin eine Abfrage. Also dass
es rot ist, das ist ja nur, dass ich sehe, dass es über die gesamte Seite drüber geht.
So und jetzt machen wir Show-Dialog standardmäßig auf True, dass ich die Übersicht habe. Okay.
So und jetzt brauchen wir irgendwie einen Dialog, der nicht mega hässlich aussieht.
Okay? Also huge CSS-Skills jetzt wieder Leute. Also was machen wir da? Also wir machen erstmal
Red. Wir machen erstmal weg. Das hier. Gut. Okay. Also. Class. Keine Ahnung. Höhe 40,
Seite 40. So. Background. Background-Color. So. Rounded. So. Absolute. Und wie kriege
ich das jetzt in die Mitte? Tailwind-Center-Element-Middle-Page. So. Das ist bestimmt irgendwie Translate oder
sowas. Nee, nee, nicht Margin und Padding. Es gibt so ein Trick mit Translate irgendwie.
Was? Margin-Left-Auto-Auto. Wirklich? Das geht? Margin. Auto. Nee. Ja. Okay. Nee, das
ging mir was mit Translate. Der Unterschied zu Bootstrap und Tailwind ist, Bootstrap ist
fertig, hat fertige Komponenten wie Buttons und sonst was. Tailwind ist eigentlich bloß
so ein Helper für Inline-Styles. War das nicht Translate? Translate? Irgendwie eins
von zwei oder irgendwie sowas? Oh nee, Alter. Nee. Nee, nee, nee. Centered-Page. Centered-Content.
Jawoll, zeig her. Ne, nee, nee, nee. Ne, nee, nee. CSS-Center-Absolute-Middle. War
da irgendwas mit Translate? Ah ja. Alter, das ist schon wieder megakompliziert. Top.
Ach, Moment. Nee, nee, Moment, Moment. Wir können das doch so machen. Wir können das
doch so machen. Center? Was war das andere? Align? Align-Middle? Nee. Wie kriege ich den
Mist jetzt in die Mitte? Item-Center ist da schon mal ganz gut. Chat-CSS-Big-Brainer-Justify-Center.
Was war das? Ah. Chat wieder next level hier. Okay. Gut. Text-Cray-100? Okay. Richtig.
Shadow. Drop. Pass mal auf hier. Drop. Shadow. Nee. Shadow? Deutlich, ich erkenne da kein
Shadow. Erkennt jeder was? Shadow. Shadow-Black. Shadow. XL. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah.
Ah. Massive-Shadow. Wie mache ich denn den Shadow jetzt ein bisschen weniger aufdringlich?
Wie mache ich denn den Shadow ein bisschen weniger aufdringlich? Box-Shadow? Shadow?
Das ist Box-Shadow? Okay. Drop-Shadow. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Drop-Shadow
und Box-Shadow? Leute, ich erkenne legit zwischen diesen Bildern keinen Unterschied. Ich sehe
zwischen diesen Bildern absolut keinen Unterschied. Ach ja, stimmt. Ich habe immer noch Dark-Reader
an. Der war schon dumm. Richtig dumm. Richtig hängen geblieben bei mir wieder. So. Drop-Shadow.
Drop-Shadow ist viel besser. Drop-Shadow-MB. Der erkenne ich. Hat das jetzt, hat das irgendwas
im Hintergrund jetzt? Ja. Tatsächlich. Leute. Tatsächlich. Ich sehe es. Ich sehe es. So,
wie macht man die, wie macht man die Color? Invert. Was? Invert? Bäh. Äh, kann man die
Farbe irgendwie ändern? Ja. Aha, jetzt erkennt man was. Richtig Massive-Shadow hier. Sieht
aber auch kacke aus. Wisst ihr was? Ignorieren wir jetzt erstmal. Ähm, denn wir haben wichtiges
zu tun. Wir müssen ein ordentliches, ein ordentliches Dialog, eine ordentliche Dialog-Box. Kann
man sagen, voll? Oh, das ist ein bisschen sehr, bisschen sehr groß. Ähm. Aber trinken
wir mal was. Okay. Also. Jetzt haben wir eine, jetzt haben wir eine Dialog-Box. Breite. Breite
50% von der Seite. Eins. Weil dann, guck mal, dann scaled nämlich unsere Dialog-Box. Seht
ihr das? Huge scaling. Oh. Ah, sorry. Epilepsy-Warnung hier wieder. Jetzt scaled. Guck mal. Bleibt
immer damit. Jetzt scaled unsere Dialog-Box mit. So, Höhe ist okay, denke ich. So. Also.
Da drinnen brauchen wir jetzt einmal einen Titel. Ähm, was weiß ich. Äh, Titel ist
Delete. Oder ne, wir machen. Wie heißt denn das unter Windows? Empty Trash? Wie heißt
Papierkorb leeren? Empty Recycle Bin. Empty. Empty Trash. Was ist Clear oder Empty? Clear
Trash. Wie heißt Clear Trash? Fragezeichen. Äh, äh, äh, äh, was? Ach so. Bin ja auch
blöd. Muss ja da rein. So, Clear Trash. So, dann braucht das noch irgendwie Padding oder
sowas. Ich kann mir immer noch nicht den Unterschied merken zwischen Padding und Margin. Padding
ist in, Margin ist nach außen. War das so? Padding ist nach in und Margin ist das, was
es nach außen hat. So, Clear Trash? Fragezeichen. Plus gleich Text. Wobei Text haben wir schon
gesessen. Haben irgendwie Text Bold. Ne, das ist Font. Also Font Dick. Und, ähm, Titel
oder so. Ich hab doch Tailwind Typography installiert. Das heißt ich kann jetzt sowas
wie H1 verwenden, oder? Ne. Hab ich nicht? Hab ich nicht? Tailwind. Tailwind Textformatierungsgeschiss
installiert. Nein, hab ich nicht. Ok. Da muss ich selbst machen. Also Clear Trash? Fragezeichen.
Wie macht man denn jetzt eine Überschrift hübsch, sodass man die sieht? Unterschied
ist wichtig, wenn du mit Borders arbeitest. So advanced bin ich ja nicht. Wobei wir können
da noch einen Border drumherum machen. Ich glaube das wird gar nicht so schlecht aussehen,
wenn wir noch einen Border drumherum machen. Border? Border? Cray? Äh. Ach Quatsch. Ich
bin auf dem falschen Element. Hier. Ja. So. Massive Box. Mach den pink. Das ist ne gute
Idee. Weil, das soll ja ins Auge staschen. Was haben wir? Pink 600 hatten wir bei den
anderen. Ja. Clear Trash. Ok. Button. Icon. Das triggert mich, dass man auf den Icons
keine on Clicks binden kann. Icon. Shadow auch pink. Ja ich bin nicht in der Lage die
Shadowfarbe gescheit zu ändern. Der Shadow ist jetzt schwarz. Ok also Icon. Ne wir brauchen
kein Icon. Wir machen einfach yes no oder? Wo haben wir denn unseren Button hier oben?
Den kopiere ich mir jetzt einfach. Wo ist unser Big Brain Button? Da. Was? Das Leerzeichen.
Ja ich weiß das ist das allerwichtigste jetzt. Ich bin ja vollkommen falsch wo ich das rein
copy paste the top. Keg weight. Jawoll. Guck mal da ist unser Button. Huge. So. Button. Und
so. Huge. Ganz ganz tolle Buttons. Class. Oho guckt euch mal an hier. Und jetzt können
wir sagen. So wie kann ich die Dinger jetzt sagen? Space around oder so? Around? Ne. Between
oder sowas? Oh ne keine Ahnung. Ich will das die Dinger links und rechts sind. Angel does
it again. Genau. Ah ich bin im falschen. Ja bin ich tatsächlich. Justify. Ja genau das
habe ich. Das habe ich gesucht. So wir könnten die Höhe eigentlich noch weg machen da ist
es nämlich nur so groß wie es sein muss. Clear trash. Guck mal das sieht doch jetzt
schon gar nicht so beschissen mehr aus. Even sieht besser aus. Ja hast recht. Guck mal
das sieht gar nicht mehr so schlecht aus jetzt. Das machen wir zu einer extra component. Genau.
Clear trash. Yes no. Es passiert jetzt natürlich noch nichts wenn man draufklickt. Guck mal
seht ihr sogar dieses Highlight von dem Button. Alter ist das poggers. Übrigens mein Drop
Shadow. Mein Drop Shadow ist kaputt wenn man das movet. Den Drop Shadow machen wir weg.
Drop Shadow. Wo ist der Drop Shadow überhaupt? Aber es sieht schon cooler aus mit Drop Shadow.
Wie sieht es mit normalem Shadow aus? Shadow. Shadow SM. Naja. Naja. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Oh ist gar nicht schlecht. So ist es gar nicht schlecht. Das ist gar nicht mal so übel
wie es jetzt ist. Den Shadow auch pink? Guck mal mal. Ach so. Nein. Den Shadow war nicht
pink. So. Aber so. Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht. Guck mal. Das geht sogar. Das ist
nicht übel. Das lassen wir jetzt so. So. Aber natürlich nicht yes no. Da kommt ein
anderes Icon hin. Das gibt es dann besser. Accept oder so. Ne. Yes. Tja. Was haben die
für Icons für yes or no? Ok. Sign? Ah. Checkmark? Ne. Yes. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Ja. Hey das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Check. Badge. Badge. Leute. Sollte. Sollte neues
Emote werden. Badge. Clipboard. Badge. Check. Check Circle. Ok. Yes. Und das andere ist.
Deny? Ne. Close. Boah. Cross? Was? X-Circle? Seriously? X-Circle. Alter da werde ich einem
Liebenden drauf kommen, dass es X-Circle heißt. X-Circle. Leute. Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Das sieht gar nicht so beschissen mehr aus. Das ist. Das ist. Das ist durchaus in Ordnung
finde ich jetzt. Clear Trash? Yes. No. Das ist wirklich ganz ok. Wie sieht es im Fullscreen
aus? Genau so. Naja. Bisschen breiter. Hat das schon eine Animation? Nein. Ähm. Die
Sache ist plus die. Soll das überhaupt mitskalieren Leute? Soll das mitskalieren? Das sieht ziemlich
unsinnig aus oder? Wenn das. Wenn das mitskaliert. Clear Trash noch Centern. Ja. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Ähm. Vielleicht. Vielleicht Centern wir das. Vielleicht. Warum lassen wir es nicht einfach
so Leute? Oder was ist denn wenn wir die Breite ganz weg machen? Ja. Was haltet ihr denn davon?
Das ist doch ok. Muss das muss die Überschrift mittig sein ja? Sehe ich das sehe ich das
richtig? Überschrift muss. Wie kriege ich wie kriege ich denn die Überschrift jetzt
mittig? Center. Was? Align Center. Center. Text Center. Ist das jetzt ist das jetzt besser?
Ok. Dann machen wir noch Padding hier. Sowas? Chat. Jetzt kann man doch nichts mehr sagen
oder? Jetzt ist es doch richtig. Ne? Ja wie? Ne. Ok P2. So. Ne so ist das gut.
So. Lassen wir das jetzt. Clear Trash. Yes. No. Perfekt. Poggers. Poggers. Ok. Yes. No.
Ehrlich gesagt ist mir egal was wir klicken. Wir machen einfach egal was und klick das
jetzt ja nur zum testen. Show. Ne das müssen wir. Show. Dialog. Gleich Falls. Logsby danke
für den Sub. Warum warum schließt sich das jetzt nicht? Ach so weil ich wieder die übliche
Geschichte nicht gemacht habe. Das ist aber auch echt hart und intuitiv. Gut. Excellent.
Guck mal hier. Ist das nicht Pog? Alter. Huge. Guck mal hier. Wie cool das jetzt aufbloppt.
So und jetzt braucht es noch eine Animation beim aufploppen. Obbei braucht das eine Animation
beim aufploppen? Wir könnten opacity irgendwie. Boah da weiß ich nicht wie das geht. Das
geht irgendwie. Translate. Was? Yes. No. Ne. Das geht. Also man kann man kann so eine
so eine Einfader Animation machen. Da bin ich mir jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz
ganz schlüssig wie. Einfach Transition. Da muss man aber bestimmt hier das Weltzeug
importieren. Fly. So. Svelte Transition. Import Fade vom Svelte Transition. Ok dann
machen wir das damit testweise. Oder Fly. Fly. So und jetzt if visible. Ja das haben wir.
Und dann sagt man was? Transition. Fly. Also. Transition. Warum gibt es das hier nicht?
Ne. Flyt da jetzt was? Das fadet eher oder? Fade. Fade. Fade. Fade. Fade. Fade. Fade.
Hä? Das ist genau das gleiche? Das habe ich bestimmt nicht richtig verwendet. Svelte.
Wir probieren es mal einfach hier drinnen aus. Fly. Fly. Svelte Transition. Fly. Hier.
Aha. Ok. Fly. Transition. Fly. X 100%. Genauso. So und nicht anders.
So wirklich Flyen tut das nicht oder? Auf Next. Fly. Hier. Wir kriegen das noch erklärt.
So. Fly. Duration. Fly. Ok. Ah. Huge.
Bisschen langsam vielleicht aber. Aber schonmal cool. Duration 200. Ja die Scrollbar können
wir dann weg machen. Ich glaube ich weiß woran die Scrollbar liegt. Das ist eigentlich ganz
cool. So Moment Scrollbar. Scrollbar off. War einfach dass die Scrollbar immer da ist.
Ne. Wir machen die Scrollbar immer weg. Wer braucht Scrollbars? Alter guck mal. Scrollbars
sind einfach mal extrem overrated, outdated, debated. Wer will denn hier bitteschön Scrollbar
haben? Das sieht hässlich aus wie die Nacht. Scrollbars kommen weg. Scrollbars werden einfach
global ausgeschaltet. Genau. Userfehler. Exakt. So jetzt können wir mal was anwenden
von dem was wir vorhin gelernt haben. Svelte. Head. Die Scrollbar Darkman. Das Problem ist
an Scrollbar stylen ist dass es mit IOS und Safari wieder nicht richtig funktioniert.
Weil da ist die Scrollbar immer weg. Sondern ist nur so ein halb durchsichtiges Ding an
der Seite. Wie so alles ja. Ne. Body. Body. Achso Moment das ist doch gar kein Style Tag.
Backweight. Style. So. Guck mal Leute. Jetzt gibt es auch keine Scrollbars mehr. Das ist
real das ich muss sagen finde ich auch dass es relativ schick aussieht jetzt. Das sieht
wirklich cool aus. Clear Trash. Yes. Die kannst du in die globale CSS machen. Du meinst
da drin. Da wo aktuell nix drin steht. Also quasi. Hoffentlich funktioniert ein Tailwind
noch wenn man hier irgendwas reinschreibt. Ja. Nice. Kann man die Icons nicht irgendwie
reloaden lassen. Das sieht hässlich aus beim Refresh wenn das immer die Icons erst laden
muss. Das ist wirklich schick. Das gefällt mir jetzt. Das sieht wirklich gut aus. Und
ich muss sagen das ist eine super super Übungs Anwendung. Weil da kann ich einfach in Zukunft
wenn ich da wieder wenn ich da wenn ich da drüber kann ich einfach hier immer nachgucken.
Das Scrollbar CSS ist sonst doppelt. Meinst du. Ja stimmt das müsste sich eigentlich
vererben ne. Ja. Genau. Wir haben nirgendswo Scrollbars. Scrollbars sind outdated overrated
gebaited in mobile Anwendungen. Ja aber ich hab hier oben ja auch Icons. Ich find das
ist echt schick. So ok. Jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir den Dialog. Clear Trash. So und
wenn ich jetzt sagen Clear Trash. Dann mach ich das da. So Empty Trash ist im Prinzip
einfach nur das da. Und Show Dialog kommt hier raus. So wenn ich sage Yes im Dialog.
Es wird mir schon wieder Blur. Brauchen wir das überhaupt noch? Ach ja. Das brauchen
wir noch. Jetzt wo es der Chat gerade sagt ich muss meinen Staubsauger auch flaschen
wieder demnächst. Den hab ich jetzt 2 Wochen oder so nur nachdem ich Reset hatte in der
Ecke stehen gehabt. Ich muss aber sagen ich bin jetzt ein bisschen von Staubsauger Robotern
ein bisschen wieder umgestiegen seit ich jetzt Homeoffice hab und mehr daheim bin. Auf zum
größten Teil mit dem Staubsauger Staubsaugern, weil das geht einfach so viel schneller.
Wohin ein Staubsauger Roboter halt irgendwie 2 Stunden rumgurgt bis er dann die erste Etage
fertig hat insgesamt. Da Fleiß ist übertrieben. Na doch doch 2 Stunden kommt schon hin. Mit
dem Staubsauger bist du in einer Viertelstunde durchgeflitzt wenn du schnell bist. Ne ich
hab das so gemacht, dass es normalerweise losfährt wenn ich nicht daheim bin. Das macht
er jetzt auch. Das funktioniert. Wenn mein Handy nicht daheim ist dann darf er. Wo sind
wir jetzt stehen geblieben? Wir sind hier bei Clear Trash. Clear Trash. Yes. Okay wenn
Yes geklickt wird, dann sagt er, wenn Yes geklickt wird macht er, ähm, remove? Ne,
wie heißt das? Empty Trash. Ich nenne das Ding Clear Trash. Weil ansonsten. Gibt es
Refactor? Rename? Oh ne das macht bestimmt wieder die Hälfte kaputt. Clear Trash. Und
äh Dialog. False. Clear Trash. Oh was ist das? Ne ne. Oh da muss ich mir noch was überlegen
gleich. Clear Trash. Yes. No. Ja und bei No macht er einfach. Ich könnte auch einfach
sagen Clear Trash. Sowas? Könnte man machen. Das müsste funktionieren. Oh jetzt ist es
nicht Brocken. Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht. Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht. Ah. Ich
deploy gleich. Warum ist das Brocken? Show Dialog ist doch auf True. Ach ist es wieder
das gleiche? Dass er das jetzt ausführt ohne? Ja das ist ja bescheuert Alter. Okay und jetzt
müsste ich hier sagen. Okay das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt schon ziemlich hässlich. Das
ist jetzt schon ziemlich hässlich. Oh ne jetzt habe ich sie gelöscht. Okay löschen.
Ne das funktioniert so nicht. Okay Funs. Oh der löscht die trotzdem? Moment der löscht
die trotzdem? Ach so. If Clear Trash. Clear. Okay wunderbar. No. Also löschen. Papierkorb
sagen. Clear. No. Es bleibt noch da. Clear. Yes. Und es ist. Ach fuck. Er sollte es doch
immer closen. Alter. Nein. False. Oh er soll den Dialog immer weg machen. So. Also paar
neue hinzufügen. Löschen, löschen, löschen. Papierkorb Ansicht. Clear All. No es passiert
nichts. Clear All. Yes alles ist weg. Okay nice. Sehr schön. Das gefällt mir. Das finde
ich gut. So und jetzt machen wir noch Show Deleted Balls. Da geht er nämlich zurück
wenn man alles geklärt hat. Zurück in die normale Ansicht. Das ist doch nice. Guck
mal. Jetzt gehen wir hier hin. So. Sagen Papierkorb Ansicht. Da brauchen wir irgendwie noch ein
gescheites Icon für gleich. Papierkorb Ansicht sagen jetzt Clear All. Yes. Zack. Da löscht
er alles und zwitscht in der zurück in die normale Ansicht. Das finde ich gut. So muss
das sein. Pogchamp. Nice. Das mag ich. Da haben wir doch heute mal richtig coole Dinger
gebastelt. Wobei hier oben brauchen wir noch irgendwas für meinen. Hier oben, dass das
ein Button ist glaube ich. Check. Hab ich deploy schon mal. Weil ihr seid Leute. Könnt ihr
euch angucken. Zack. Da sind wir. Könnt ihr mal gehen auf ToDoCacW.Services.
Oh. Ich hab standardmäßig immer noch auf True stehen. Das Ganze. Nein. Nein. Nein.
Das muss ich gleich. Siehst du. Ist da erst mal direkt Production Deployed. Show Deleted
Balls. Und Show Dialog Balls. So. Wird das einfach nur. Das wird eine ToDo List Anwendung
zum Weltüben. Genau. Correct. ToDo List sind ja quasi die Hello Worlds des Internets. Aus
Funst. Guck mal hier. Nice. Zack. Zack. Zack. Papierkorb. Löschen. Papierkorb Ansicht.
Restore. Und den Rest. Delete All. Yes. Und alles weg. Pogchamp. Das ist richtig gut.
Das. Das gefällt mir. Und ich muss sagen. Das war richtig Big Brain vom Chat. Also was
mit dem Alken da oben in der Ecke los ist habe ich immer noch nicht. Ja die. Die. Die.
Die Progress Bar. Die. Die stimmt immer noch nicht. Die Progress Bar. Da muss man so was
überlegen. Die ist sus. Ach so. So der Nachricht Papierkorb ist leer. Ich glaube das brauchen
wir nicht. Weil. Wenn du den Papierkorb leerst. Dann verschwinden dir alles und es wird dich
wieder in die normale Ansicht. Ist die Progress Bar kaputt. Die Progress Bar ist kaputt weil
wenn ich Sachen lösche dann dürfen die nicht im Progress auftauchen. Ok. Progress Percent
ist to do filter done. Und not not deleted. Ja. Ach jetzt muss ich den Kram hier auch
nochmal filtern. Ok jetzt muss ich das auslagern. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eklig. Jetzt stimmt
es nicht weil die Länge nicht stimmt. Jetzt ist ja nicht mal Länge insgesamt. Sondern
Länge quasi Bilder die nicht nicht deleted sind. Das sieht jetzt aber hässlich aus.
Ja guckt jetzt funktioniert es. Jetzt funktioniert es. Der Papierkorb wird da nicht mehr mitgerechnet.
Was in der Desktop Ansicht taucht bei mir rechts eine Scrollbar auf. Beim auf den Delete
Button klicken. Das sollte eigentlich nicht so sein. Das ist wieder so eine Browser Geschichte
weg. Pass auf im FireFox ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt kaputt. Wahrscheinlich ist es im FireFox
jetzt kaputt. Warum ist es im FireFox jetzt kaputt. Warum ist es im FireFox jetzt kaputt.
Braucht man noch extra was für Mozilla. Ne das ist ergeblich FireFox. Ergeblich sollte
das im FireFox. Hast du FireFox. Gibt es noch etwas wie Mods. Scroll. Ja eigentlich
sollte das für alle gesetzt sein. Jetzt ist es aber anscheinend nicht. Es gibt kein extra
für Mozilla. So aber der Rest ist schon mal in Ordnung. Hier oben für das umschalten
müssen wir uns jetzt noch was ordentliches überlegen. Geht die Suche eigentlich. Ja
die geht. Das haben wir richtig gemacht. Checken wir mal wirklich ob die Suche geht. 1,2,3
umschalten. Ja die Suche funzt immer. Eigentlich bräuchten wir jetzt so ein Toggle Ding. Wie
heisst denn das. Switch. So was bräuchten wir. Genau. So was bräuchten wir eigentlich.
Label Class Input Type. Was. Ach so was gibt es nicht fertig im Browser oder was. So was
will ich nicht selber machen. Das habe ich schon gefixt mit dem wenn du no drückst.
Da müsste ich nur nochmal neu pushen. Wenn du no drückst bleibt die jetzt drinnen im
Papierkorb. So. Also jetzt müssen wir diesen Button da oben weg machen. Also hier machen
wir ich glaube das machen wir das nächste Mal. Dass wir hier ne ordentliche Komponente
draus machen. Wir machen diesen hässlichen Button weg. Ich finde den Button schon gar
nicht mehr. Wo ist der Button. Wo ist der Button mit Klick drauf. Klick. Button. Ist
das der Button. Ja. So. Jetzt bräuchten wir irgendwie nen ordentlichen Switch. Ich weiß
nicht so genau wo wir den hin machen. Wo machen wir den Switch hin. Für Papierkorb an und
aus. Wir können ja nicht noch nen Ding hier neben machen oder. Wobei es eigentlich thematisch
ist. Leute doch wir machen das da hin und machen die Suchleiste oben drüber. Das können
wir nix hin machen. Neben default kommen ja noch die ganzen anderen Notizbücher die
ich es geben kann. Wir machen das jetzt einfach hier hin. Erstmal search. WB chain lore wir
machen das erstmal hier hin. Die Sache ist nur die. Ich bin wirklich nicht. Ich sehe
mich jetzt auf kurzfristig nicht in der Lage einen schönen CSS Toggle Switch zu bauen.
Oha. Guckt euch das an. Koggas Toggle Switch. Dabei ist das gar nicht so kompliziert wie
es aussieht. Ich will kein fertiges UI Kit verwenden. Simple switch CSS. Simple CSS Toggle
Switch. Simple. Simple. Nee das ist finde ich nicht simple. Switch. Switch input. Switch.
Switch diff. Alter. Übertreibs halt mal. Gibt es da nicht irgendwas mit drei Zeilen.
Simple. Alter das sind alles fünf Seiten lang. Hellwind Components. Excellent. Toggle
me. Ja Gachibas Toggle mich. So wie kann man das jetzt einbinden? Kann man dann irgendwie
sagen Component Toggle Switch oder so? Moment. Achso ich dachte ich kann das. Ich dachte
ich kann das hier irgendwie. Ich dachte ich kann das hier irgendwie einbinden als Plugin.
Und dann ist gut. Download. Nee das ist anscheinend wirklich Copy Paste. Copy Paste. Ey mein
das ist schon relativ simple. Das nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal. Ich Copy Paste, nehme
das jetzt raus. Wir machen jetzt mal kurz. Wir machen mal schnell eine neue Component
dafür. Switch. Welt. Zack. Jaja MonkaS. So. Script. Script. Weiß gar nicht ob wir
das überhaupt brauchen. So Class Inline. Gut und jetzt binden wir das ein. Switch.
Okay das Ding hat irgendeinen Sonntagsfehler drin. Apply. Oh ist das das? Ist Apply ist
das das? Oder was ist das? Oder warum funktioniert das nicht? Nee oder was ist das? Ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was ich damit anfangen soll. Ist Post CSS? Ja wunderbar. Pog oder not
Pog? Nee MonkaW machen wir nicht. Wir haben so viele MonkaEmo's schon. Machen wir einfach
weg. So Switch. So und jetzt binden wir den mal ein. Gucken ob der irgendwie was taugt.
Ja. Gut ich hab ja auch die Sachen gelöscht. Switch. Was macht Apply? Okay ich hab keine
Ahnung was das macht. Da bin ich zur Pepega für. Kein Schimmer. Toggle me. Ah gut. Ich
meine es ist kein schöner Switch. Warum funktioniert das nicht? Da muss ja was geben. Simple. Also
Toggle Checkshop bekommt alle Styles von allen Klassen die im Apply drin sind. Ja schön
und gut aber Apply. Ich weiß nicht warum das bei mir nicht funktioniert. Weil Post CSS
nicht funktioniert oder was? Muss ich das nicht in Style machen? Wo hab ich denn? Components?
Wie verwendet man das? Style? Nö. Muss das hier vielleicht irgendwie in meine? Nee oder?
Unown Rule. Unown Rule. Ja das ist irgendwie eine Magic die wahrscheinlich total simpel
ist wenn man weiß was man macht. Aha. Aha. Lange Post CSS. Lange Post CSS. Lange Post
CSS. Aha. Es hört sich vielleicht so an aber ich hab keine Ahnung was abgeht. Ähm.
Okay Lack of Critical Information. Keine Ahnung. Das ist irgendwie irgendwelche Magic im Hintergrund
die nicht läuft weil keine Ahnung. Was haben wir nochmal? Sveiled? Add? Da haben wir doch
irgendwie so ein komisches. Add. Ja. So das haben wir verwendet. So Apply. Erzähl mir
wie es funktioniert. Issues. Hier. Da stand noch was. Apply. Apply. You can use Style
CSS Blocks. Aha. Aber ja ich muss Post CSS installieren aber sollte der mir nicht eigentlich
sein. Ich habe kein Post CSS installiert. Also machen wir das dann mal. Wobei NPM List
Posts. Posts. Ist nicht installiert. Style Lange Post CSS. Haben wir doch gemacht.
Na. Wird da irgendwas? Ich meine.
Was macht dieses Ding? Deswegen mag ich das nicht wenn zu viel Magic im Hintergrund ist
weil ich dann keine Ahnung hab was eigentlich passiert. Stuff. Bester Name. Stuff JS. Obvious.
Ich installiere jetzt einfach Post CSS.
Moment. Guck mal. Hier sind Applies. Haben wir überhaupt keinen Doppelpunkt mehr dahinter.
Aber es funktioniert auch nicht. Macht überhaupt keinen Unter. Ah. Ok. Das macht schon was.
Funktioniert nicht. Alter ist das freudig. Das machen wir heute nicht mehr Leute. Das
machen wir heute nicht mehr. Das machen wir heute mal. Das reicht mir für heute wieder.
Also was haben wir geschafft? Wir haben den Delete All Button. Wir haben einen Papierkorb
so halb. So Minus. Such haben wir auch geschafft. Wo ist der Delete All? Der Delete All Knopf
ist ja den kannst du grad nicht sehen weil ich den durch diesen Toggle Button ersetzen
wollte. Du musst in die Papierkorb Ansicht wechseln aber das funktioniert gerade nicht
weil Toggle. Ich mein ich kanns ja mal kurz wieder einbinden. Was passiert eigentlich
wenn ich den ganzen Shit hier weg mache? Ok dann Toggles gar nichts mehr alles klar.
Ist das ReactOS? Ja. Eindeutig ist das ReactOS. Ok also hier wird getoggelt. Toggle me. Kommt
weg. Braucht kein Text. Das Label. Brauchen wir das Label überhaupt? Nö null. Kein Label.
Oder wahrscheinlich ist es sonst broken. So. Und jetzt müssen wir irgendein Event schmeißen
wenn das hier getoggelt wird. Also Let. Nee war das der Export. Let. Active oder sowas.
Active. Und wo bekommt man überhaupt jetzt mit wenn das getoggelt wird. Input. Checkbox.
Hier bekommt man das mit. Find. Checked. Active. Ja ja ich weiß ich muss es klammern.
So das sollte jetzt eigentlich funsten. Gucken wir mal. Active. Ok. False. Ok. Es sieht halt
mega beschissen aus. Aber immerhin. Das machen wir das nächste Mal machen wir das ordentlich.
So. Let. Active. Gut. So. Kann man das jetzt binden irgendwie hier von von oben drüber.
Switch. Active. Also ich quasi sage hier. Bind. Show. Deleted. Nee. Bind. Active. Show
Deleted. 30 Monate. Richtig poggers. Hey Funds guck mal. Die Papierkorb umschalte Anzeige
ist da. Nur das der Switch halt richtig extremst hängen geblieben aussieht. Aber ich push
es jetzt trotzdem. Ja Massive. Richtig richtig. Hyper Subscription am Start. Wieso ist das
Scrollbar Label User Selectable. Es ist eine gute Frage. Weil das Crap ist was die Typen
gebaut haben da wahrscheinlich. Einmal das Scrollbar. Welches Scrollbar Label. NPM install
kann ich das einfach wieder aninstall machen. Es geht immer noch. Ok funktioniert immer
noch alles. Alles gut. Die 33 Prozent waren gerade mal hier. Stimmt warum ist das Selectable.
Ja das ist dumm. Das können wir das können wir weg machen. Procress. Procress. Weil das
einfach hier ist. Select. User Select ist glaube ich User. Select. User Select. Select.
Select none ist es. Ok jetzt kannst du nix mehr selecten. Das bleibt jetzt da oben.
Das sieht zwar beschissen aus. Aber. Also es würde gar nicht so beschissen aussehen.
Wenn. Das kein Haken macht. So wenn ich das hier wenn ich das hier weg mache dann funs
es schon mal nicht. Wobei doch funs immer noch. Und warum. Was genau war jetzt der Sinn
davon von diesem Apply. Ich sehe da überhaupt keinen Unterschied dazwischen. Ich muss doch
ich muss doch eigentlich nur dafür sorgen dass da kein Checkmark reinkommt. Das Toggle
kannst du noch nicht verstehen. Das ist einfach random drin. Was das Toggle machen soll ist
Ansicht zwischen Papierkorb und normal. Wenn du irgendwie andere in Big Brain Ideen hast
außer den Switch. Der sagt mir irgendwas. Das Switch zwischen Papierkorb Ansicht und
normal. Du musst nur die Background Color setzen beim checkt oder. Passt. Es passt
eigentlich alles. Ich will. Ich will das wegbekommen dass der überhaupt. Da noch ein Checkmark
und so komische Kringel drum herum hat soll soll alles weg. Papierkorb Eichen. Wir können
da neben Papierkorb Eichen machen. Ich will jetzt aber erst mal gucken wie man das mit
der Toggle hinkriegt. Was ist denn das hier wieder. Wie kann ich das
stylen dass das Checkmark Ding wegkommt. CSS. Height. Check. Sign. Checkmark. Na. Das
ist eine bescheuerte Antwort. Was. Was. Was ist denn. Alter. Ist der Golfer Flau. Was
ist denn mit euch los. Alter ist das wieder kompliziert.
Macht doch ein Toggle wie in den Battlefield Settings. Es sieht von der Farbe fast schon
ein bisschen nach Battlefield Settings aus. Das ist außen drum herum. Aha. Das hier ist
das Ding schon mal. Outline Null. Der Unterschied. Border. Border. Null. Oh ne. Ach ne das ist
on hover wieder hier ne. On Focus. Das ist wieder. Focus. Boah ist das Känzer des stylen
das Zeug. Alter. Meine Güte. Das bleibt jetzt so. Das bleibt jetzt so. Da habe ich jetzt
keine Musel für das mir zu überlegen. Das lasse ich jetzt so. Und das nächste Mal machen
wir das dann schon noch. Und lagern den Kram auch in Komponenten aus und sowas. Das ist
gerade. Das reicht mir. So. Git. Status. Add. Push. Force. Immer schön Force pushen.
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen. Ah ne ich habe vergessen. Komm. Komm jetzt. Ja ich habe
Local Storage gefixt. Ich weiß nicht warum. KQ. Giga. Chat. Push. Alles klar. So. Wer
sich das angucken will. Source Code technisch. Ist. Falsches Repo. Ist hier am Start. Ist
hier am Start auf GitHub. Und. Auf. To do. Punkt. Kek. W. Punkt. Services. Oh ich muss
noch deployen. Playbook. Bäm. So. Jetzt habt ihr uns ein komisches Toggl. Alter. Sieht
richtig angeblieben aus. Oh Leute. Es gibt ein Problem. Wir haben das nicht richtig angepasst
mit der Prozent Anzeige. Es gäbe da so ein kleines Problem.
So. Jetzt also. Anzeige. Papierkorb. Löschen. Aber das finde ich cool. Das hat es mir echt
echt. Alter der Firefox mit seinem komischen. Dumm. Scrollbar. Das hat es mir echt angetan.
Clear Trash. No. Clear Trash. Yes. Das finde ich ist cool. Auch wie das ein faded und so.
Richtig Pogchamp. Das gefällt mir. Leider. Leider ist das mit der. Mit der Firefox Scrollbar
so ein bisschen so ein Ding. Der Toggl wird nicht geblurrt. Oh. Na gut. Man kann nicht
alles haben. Ich weiß warum der nicht geblurrt wird. Ist eigentlich ganz einfach warum der
Toggl nicht geblurrt wird. Das ist weil ich den nicht im Diff drinne hab. Guck hier. Und
jetzt wird es ja auch geblurrt. Weil ihr seid chat. Oh. Status. Bam. Überschreiben wir
den Kram mal wieder. Shit. Repo. So jetzt wird auch. Jetzt wird auch geblurrt. Ups.
Jetzt wird auch ordentlich geblurrt hier oben. Was passiert eigentlich mit Ausrufezeichen
Hetzner mit dem zweiten. Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich hab mir für nächstes Jahr mit
dem noch nichts überlegt. Aber sag mal so von meiner Seite aus würde ich das weitermachen.
Und ich guck mal ob die irgendwelche Mails geschrieben haben. Und ich glaube auch dass
das zahlentechnisch bei denen nicht schlecht war. Also auch so exposure technisch. Man kann
es ja nicht immer nur anhand von irgendwelchen Anmeldungen messen. Also ich denke mal das
geht nächstes Jahr weiter. Wird sich zeigen. Müssen wir mal gucken. Nach wie vielen Tagen
verfällt das. Oh das ist eine gute Idee für Big Brain Feature. Papierkorb. Wie macht
man das auch mal? Papierkorb verfällt nach 14 Tagen. 7 Tagen. Was auch immer. Dein Hetzner
Guthaben. Wenn du das eingelöst hast sollte das da bleiben. Also ihr könnt euch noch wer
es jetzt noch nicht gesehen hat. Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in Chat. Ihr könnt euch einen 20
Euro Cloud Guthaben sichern. Bei Hetzner Cloud. Mit meinem Anmeldecode. Das müsst ihr aber
einlösen bis 31 in 12. Und ich glaube alles was eingelöst ist bis dahin bleibt erhalten.
Kleine Comets. Overrated. Outdated. Shebaited. Ja und ich mein. Guck mal. Mit 20 Euro könnt
ihr ja schon eine Triple Core Kiste fast 3 Monate laufen lassen. Das ist nicht übel.
Aber insgesamt muss man sagen haben wir heute trotzdem ganz gut Progress gemacht. Auch wenn
das jetzt gerade ein bisschen hässlich aussieht hier. Aber es ist nicht verkehrt. Und ich
muss sagen gerade dieses Papierkorb leeren hat es mir wirklich angetan. Das finde ich
sehr sehr. Wieso benutzt du das Profilbild von Max FPS ja krass krass abgerippt hier.
Du brauchst nicht Deutsch zu wissen. CAC ist glaubbar. CAC W. Aber in Deutsch ist es CAC
W. Because W equals W. Ja mir gefällt das wirklich das hat was. Das hat was. Wobei
ich mir immer noch ziemlich sicher bin dass ich hier einen Bug gefunden habe. Dass man
diese Geschichte hier braucht. Dass man das braucht. Ich glaube das ist ein Bug. Das ergibt
sonst keinen Sinn. One Englischer Stream ja. Nie. Wisst ihr was ich gerade gefunden habe
hier auf Basteltisch. Was ist das? Das ist der ihr wisst es genau. Chat. Was ist das?
Smoke fast. Da haben wir es auch. Ist der abisoliert Champ. So richtig. Das ist nicht
illegal. Kannst einen neuen Account machen. Aber ich soll das nicht so explizit bewerben
haben sie immer gesagt. Das geht aber es geht. Letztendlich ist es für mich ja nicht verkehrt.
Umso mehr Leute sich neu anmelden umso besser sieht meine Statistik aus. W. Stonks genau.
Ach ja. Ja Leute. Ich weiß. Gute Idee. Ich wollte eigentlich noch ein Video machen. Was
ich alles auf mein. Wie sage ich das anders sagen. Ich wollte eigentlich ein Video aufnehmen
noch. Weil wir letztes Video gesehen haben. So was wollte ich auch machen. Nur dass ich
das wahrscheinlich nicht alles in einem Video machen werde. Weil zu viel ist. Ich mache
mir extra für euch ein Dashboard habe ich mir überlegt. Weil das kommt in YouTube Videos
immer gut an wenn man Dashboards hat. Dashboards wirken einfach besser als wenn ich Kommandozeile
aufmache. Den Krieger Rainn. Dass ihr wieder etwas auf den Kopf fällt. Wild. Was macht
er denn gerade. Red Dead Redemption 2. Das juckt mich ja so gar nicht. Weil das nächste
Battlefield 3. Keine Ahnung. Echt. Kein Plan. Spielst du noch Battlefield 4. Nee Battlefield
3 habe ich nicht inszeniert. C++ Stream. Welchen C++ Stream soll ich hosten. Sag es mir. Gucken
wir mal. Twitch. Software. Endgame Development. Welchen C++ Hacker Mann oder Hacker Frau hosten
wir denn. Guck mal. Ich bin. Ach auf Deutsch. Okay. Trotzdem. Ich bin auf Platz 1. In diese
Kategorie streamt einfach keiner. Empfohlene Kanäle Wubblos. Wie jetzt. Was. Ist das nicht
nach Zuschauern gedingst. Doch. Einfach gerade sagen. Es sah aus als hat er nichts an. Aber
das ist das T-Shirt. Nee keine Ahnung Leute. Aber ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr konzentrieren
ich haue jetzt einfach ab. Was. Was macht er. Sagt mir nichts. Ich ich haue es am liebsten
Leute den ich selbst haue. Aber es ist niemand. Und. Also dies bräuchten. Richtig pence
gempe ich. Warte noch mal. Leute ich gehe jetzt auf. Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's
gut zu.